Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Dear Mr. Potter, We are pleased to inform ye that ye have a place at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and Wizardry. Please find enclosed a list of all necessary books and equipment. Term begins on the 1st of September. We await your all by no later than the 31st of July. Yours sincerely,
感谢您收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。亲爱的波特先生：我们很高兴地通知您，您已获准在霍格沃茨魔法学校就读。随信附上所需书籍及装备清单。学期将于9月1日开始。我们期待您在7月31日前给予答复。您诚挚的，
Minerva McGonagall, Deputy Headmistress. So that, Dominic, as the half a billion people who I gather have read Harry Potter across the world will need no telling, is from J.K. Rowling's Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone, published in 1997. And as the author of The Great British Dream Factory, The Strange History of Our National Imagination, a book that looks at the impact of British culture on the imagination of the world, how would you rate the impact of J.K. Rowling? Well, first of all, everybody, I'm so sorry. I actually suggested to Tom that he do that in a Scottish accent. And now I've paid the price, I suppose.
米勒娃·麦格，副校长。多米尼克，正如全世界据我估计有五亿人读过《哈利·波特》的人所知，这段话出自J.K.罗琳1997年出版的《哈利·波特与魔法石》。作为《大英梦工厂：我们民族想象力的奇异历史》（The Great British Dream Factory, The Strange History of Our National Imagination）一书的作者，该书探讨了英国文化对世界想象力的影响，你如何评价J.K.罗琳的影响力？好吧，首先，各位，我非常抱歉。其实是我建议汤姆用苏格兰口音来读那段话的。我想，现在我自食其果了。
Well, it was the accent of Maggie Smith. Right. Of course, plays Miss McGonagall in the film. Is it Miss McGonagall? Miss McGonagall, it must be. Professor Tom. Professor McGonagall. Give her a title. You're doing that thing that people always do with female academics, aren't you? You're downgrading them.
嗯，那是玛吉·史密斯的口音。没错。当然，她在电影里饰演麦格教授。是麦格小姐吗？一定是麦格教授。汤姆教授。麦格教授。给她个头衔吧。你又在做人们对待女性学者时常做的那种事了，对吧？你在贬低她们。
Yes, I am. I apologize. It was a more sophisticated impression then than I gave it credit for. You're doing Maggie Smith doing a voice, aren't you downgrading them yes i am i apologize it was a more sophisticated impression than i gave it credit for because you know you're doing maggie smith doing a voice aren't you yes so harry potter it's an extraordinary phenomenon isn't it and um i underrated it actually in that book you talked about the great british dream factory and i think i was wrong you're very rude about it i was wrong because harry potter um has a claim it's one of the single most important stories in the minds of people under the age of, what, 30, 35, who've grown up with these stories. And one of the reasons J.K. Rowling is now so controversial is that for some people, she had the status of a kind of moral
是的，我确实在这样做。我道歉。那段模仿比我预想的要高明得多。你是在模仿玛吉·史密斯说话，对吧？你确实在贬低她们，是的，我道歉。那段模仿比我预想的要高明得多，因为你知道，你是在模仿玛吉·史密斯说话，对吧？是的，所以《哈利·波特》是一个非凡的现象，不是吗？嗯，我在你提到的那本《大英梦工厂》里其实低估了它，我想我错了。你对它评价很刻薄。我错了，因为《哈利·波特》……它有资格成为30岁、35岁以下人群心中最重要的故事之一，他们是伴随着这些故事长大的。J.K.罗琳现在之所以如此充满争议，原因之一在于对某些人来说，她曾拥有一种道德导师的地位，不是吗？
teacher, didn't she? Yes. And a lot of people will say, I got my moral code from Harry Potter. Yes. So it's not just entertainment. It carries this kind of charge, which has always been the case with some children's stories, as we will see in this podcast. Because Dominic, a question. Do stories about people going away to boarding schools that carry a hefty moral charge, is this something that J.K.
是的。很多人会说，我的道德准则来自《哈利·波特》。是的。所以它不仅仅是娱乐。它承载着某种力量，正如我们将在本期播客中看到的那样，这在某些儿童故事中一直如此。因为多米尼克，有个问题。关于人们去寄宿学校并承载沉重道德负担的故事，这是J.K.
Rowling has invented? No. Or does it have a long lineage? That's a lovely link, Tom. Absolutely beautifully unscripted. It does have a long lineage. So when you advertised this episode on social media, you said we were going to be talking about the origins of Harry Potter,
罗琳发明的吗？不是。还是说它有着悠久的渊源？汤姆，这个衔接真棒。绝对是即兴发挥，非常精彩。它确实有着悠久的渊源。所以当你在社交媒体上宣传这一集时，你说我们要谈论《哈利·波特》的起源，
the stories behind Harry Potter. I saw there were a stream of replies in which people were saying, are you going to talk about this? Are you going to talk about that? And there's a whole load of books that people have pointed to in the past. So the stories of Enid Blyton, the Narnia stories or Tolkien, The Dark is Rising sequence by Susan Cooper. Have you read that, Tom? I have. In your book, you also cite Sword in the Stone. Sword in the Stone by T.H. White. People point to The Worst Witch by Jill Murphy,
《哈利·波特》背后的故事。我看到有一连串的回复，人们在问，你们会谈论这个吗？你们会谈论那个吗？过去人们指出了很多书。比如伊妮德·布莱顿的故事、《纳尼亚传奇》或托尔金的作品、苏珊·库珀的《黑暗崛起》系列。汤姆，你读过吗？我读过。在你的书中，你还提到了《石中剑》。T.H.怀特的《石中剑》。人们还提到了吉尔·墨菲的《最糟糕的女巫》，
the Crestomancy stories by Diana Wynne-Jones, or the Discworld stories by Terry Pratchett. And I think one of the reasons for J.K. Rowling's success actually is she wove lots of elements of those stories. Or you could say that she is drawing on the material that all those other authors are also drawing on. Yes. So at his heart, I think, I would argue, and I'm not the first person to argue this by any means, at the heart of Harry Potter is a school story. I mean, that is the essential trajectory of the story. It's a coming-of-age story in which, I mean, who listening to this doesn't know that Harry is an orphan who grows up under the stairs in his kind of foster family's suburban house.
戴安娜·温·琼斯的《克雷斯托曼西》系列，或者特里·普拉切特的《碟形世界》系列。我认为J.K.罗琳成功的原因之一，实际上是她编织了这些故事中的许多元素。或者你可以说，她正在汲取所有其他作者也在汲取的素材。是的。所以我想我会争辩说，而且我绝不是第一个提出这一点的人，在《哈利·波特》的核心，是一个校园故事。我的意思是，这是故事的基本轨迹。这是一个成长故事，我的意思是，听众里谁不知道哈利是一个孤儿，在寄宿家庭郊区的楼梯下长大呢？
And he has this remarkable letter that you read out so beautifully at the beginning of the program. And off he goes to school, to a boarding school, to learn witchcraft and wizardry. And that device, the boy who goes from kind of obscurity, discovers the school, this extraordinary medieval building, is introduced to new friends, to the school bully, to scary teachers, to new codes, to a secret language, all of that kind of stuff. That is a very old device in British fiction. So Dominic, could I just read a passage from a novel that I read over the weekend in preparation for recording this episode? Do Tom, I'd love that. And it describes a boy going to a boarding school, very like Harry Potter goes to Hogwarts.
他收到了那封你在节目开头读得如此动人的非凡信件。然后他去上学了，去了一所寄宿学校，学习巫术和魔法。而那个装置，那个从默默无闻中走出来的男孩，发现了学校，这座非凡的中世纪建筑，被介绍给新朋友、学校恶霸、可怕的老师、新的准则、一种秘密语言，所有这些东西。这在英国小说中是一个非常古老的装置。所以多米尼克，我能读一段我在周末为录制本集做准备时读到的小说片段吗？读吧，汤姆，我很乐意。它描述了一个男孩去寄宿学校，非常像哈利·波特去霍格沃茨。
Tom followed his guide through the schoolhouse hall, which opens into the quadrangle. It is a great room, 30 feet long and 18 high or thereabouts, with two great tables running the whole length and two large fireplaces at the side with blazing fires in them. Obviously, I don't need to tell you, of all people, that that comes from Tom Brown's school days, written by Thomas Hughes, published in 1857, and a book of which you say, it is hard to think of many other Victorian books, indeed many other books of any era, that have left such a deep imprint on the British imagination. Yeah, I stand by what I said. You agree with yourself? I agree with myself. Shocking scenes. So Tom Brown's School Days, for people who don't know, as I said,
汤姆跟着他的向导穿过校舍大厅，大厅通向方庭。这是一个大房间，长30英尺，高18英尺左右，有两张长桌贯穿整个长度，两侧有两个大壁炉，里面燃着熊熊大火。显然，我不需要告诉你，你当然知道，这段话出自托马斯·休斯于1857年出版的《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》，你说过，很难想到还有哪本维多利亚时代的书，甚至任何时代的书，能对英国人的想象力留下如此深刻的印记。是的，我坚持我的说法。你同意你自己的观点？我同意我自己的观点。令人震惊的场面。所以《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》，对于不知道的人来说，正如我所说，
written in the 1850s, it is a foundational text of Victorian Britain, and not just of Victorian Britain, of schools all around the world. It's a foundational text of the culture of international sport. Yeah, so the Olympics and all that comes from this, doesn't it? Organized sports, of the idea of manliness, the idea of service, of moral character, all of these things. It's one of the best-selling books in any genre of the idea of manliness, the idea of service, of moral character, all of these things. It's one of the best-selling books in any genre of the 19th century. As late as 1940, it was still one of the top four books read by British children after Treasure Island, Robinson Crusoe, and I think it's something that maybe Gulliver's Travels or something like that. So I had never read it.
写于19世纪50年代，它是维多利亚时代英国的奠基性文本，不仅是维多利亚时代英国的，也是世界各地学校的奠基性文本。它是国际体育文化的奠基性文本。是的，所以奥运会和所有这些都源于此，不是吗？有组织的体育运动，关于男子气概的理念，关于服务、道德品质的理念，所有这些东西。它是19世纪任何类型中最畅销的书籍之一。直到1940年，它仍然是英国儿童阅读量前四名的书籍之一，仅次于《金银岛》、《鲁滨逊漂流记》，我想还有《格列佛游记》之类的书。所以我以前从未读过它。
I have read Flashman, who is the bully in Tom Brown's school days, who tosses Tom Brown in a blanket and roasts him in front of a fire and all kinds of things like that. And it becomes the hero of George MacDonald Fraser's series of novels in which Flashman, this coward, poltroon and bully, becomes a much garlanded hero. And so I had always assumed from that that Tom Brown himself was a terrible kind of wuss and a wet, but actually he isn't at all. And the story is great. I mean, it's very, very gripping. I really enjoyed it.
我读过《弗莱什曼》，他是《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》里的恶霸，他把汤姆·布朗扔进毯子里，在火前烤他，还有各种各样的事情。他成为了乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽系列小说的英雄，其中弗莱什曼这个懦夫、胆小鬼和恶霸，变成了一个备受赞誉的英雄。所以我一直以为汤姆·布朗本人是个糟糕的懦夫和软蛋，但实际上他根本不是。这个故事很棒。我的意思是，它非常、非常引人入胜。我真的很喜欢它。
Well, it's effective with the story. It's all school stories. It is, yes. So Tom arrives. Well, just to give you a sense of the story, I suppose, before we talk about the story behind the story. So Tom is from rural Berkshire. He's a kind of kind-hearted athletic boy, a bit of a sort of a rascal.
嗯，它对故事很有效。全是校园故事。是的，确实。所以汤姆到了。嗯，只是为了让你对这个故事有个概念，我想，在我们谈论故事背后的故事之前。所以汤姆来自伯克郡农村。他是一个心地善良、热爱运动的男孩，有点像个淘气鬼。
His father, the squire, when Tom is 11, decides to send him to rugby school to make a gentleman of him, I suppose. And to make a man of him. And to make a man of him. And Tom goes to rugby. He falls in with a friend straight away, his version of Ron Weasley, Harry Potter's friend. His friend is called Harry- Scud East.
当汤姆11岁时，他的父亲，那位乡绅，决定把他送到拉格比公学，我想是为了让他成为一个绅士。为了让他成为一个男人。为了让他成为一个男人。汤姆去了拉格比。他立刻交到了一个朋友，他版本的罗恩·韦斯莱，哈利·波特的伙伴。他的朋友叫哈里·斯库德·伊斯特。
Scud East. Yeah. There's a school bully, a Draco Malfoy, who is Harry Flashman, who then becomes the hero of his own series of novels. Tom goes through a series of trials. He cheats, doesn't he, in his lessons and ends up reforming. He adopts a boy called George Arthur, who is a cross between, if you've read Harry Potter, for the Harry Potter fans, he's like a cross between Dobby the House Elf and Neville Longbottom, so Harry's useless friend. He's a kind of angelic swat, isn't he? He is.
斯库德·伊斯特。是的。有一个学校恶霸，一个德拉科·马尔福，就是哈里·弗莱什曼，后来成为了他自己系列小说的英雄。汤姆经历了一系列考验。他在功课上作弊，不是吗？最后改过自新。他收养了一个叫乔治·阿瑟的男孩，如果你读过《哈利·波特》，对于哈利·波特的粉丝来说，他就像是多比小精灵和纳威·隆巴顿的结合体，也就是哈利那个没用的朋友。他是个天使般的书呆子，不是吗？他是。
I was very amused to see that evidence for his swattishness is that he reads Herodotus for pleasure. Well, not only that, Tom. Most famously, he prays, doesn't he? Yes, he does. He prays by his bedside. He shames the other boys into praying by there. But this is a tremendously transformative moment for Tom Brown. So he previously
我很有趣地发现，他书呆子气的证据是他读希罗多德是为了消遣。嗯，不仅如此，汤姆。最著名的是，他祈祷，不是吗？是的，他祈祷。他在床边祈祷。他让其他男孩因为祈祷而感到羞愧。但这对汤姆·布朗来说是一个巨大的转变时刻。所以他之前
hasn't been praying. He's been embarrassed to do it. And he is shamed by this weedy little wretch into praying every night. It's a very, I find it quite a moving scene, Tom, because I kind of admire
没有祈祷。他一直不好意思这样做。他被这个瘦弱的小可怜羞辱得每晚都祈祷。汤姆，我觉得这是一个非常感人的场景，因为我有点钦佩
that moral earnestness. Well, now I find out. Yeah. After whatever, 350 episodes of you bullying me like Flashman. Exactly. Tom because I kind of admire that moral earnestness well now I find out yeah after whatever 350 episodes of you climbing me like flashback exactly if you just mention this you bring a tear to my eye see there's the final scene which is a cricket match isn't it climb the climax is a cricket match yeah brilliant where Tom puts uh George Arthur into into bat doesn't he and he does really quite well he does all right they lose though don't they they still lose yeah they still lose but
那种道德上的真诚。好吧，现在我发现了。是的。在经历了350集你像弗莱什曼一样欺负我之后。正是如此。汤姆，因为我有点钦佩那种道德上的真诚，好吧，现在我发现了，是的，在经历了350集你像弗莱什曼一样欺负我之后，正是如此，如果你只是提到这一点，你就会让我热泪盈眶，看，最后一场戏是板球比赛，不是吗？高潮是一场板球比赛，是的，太棒了，汤姆让乔治·阿瑟上场击球，不是吗？他做得相当不错，他做得还可以，但他们输了，不是吗？他们还是输了，是的，他们还是输了，但
that's fine you know it's playing the game and all right. They lose though, don't they? They still lose. Yeah, they still lose, but that's fine. You know, it's playing the game. And also they have a brilliant boxing match, don't they? They do. With Slugger Williams. Bizarre. There's going to be a fight. Oh, Slugger Williams, between Slugger Williams and Tom Brown.
没关系，你知道，这就是参与比赛，没关系。他们输了，不是吗？他们还是输了。是的，他们还是输了，但没关系。你知道，这就是参与比赛。而且他们还有一场精彩的拳击比赛，不是吗？他们有。和“重击手”威廉姆斯。太离奇了。要打架了。哦，“重击手”威廉姆斯，在“重击手”威廉姆斯和汤姆·布朗之间。
And the Slugger is massive. Yeah. Absolute, you know, Mike Tyson or whatever. But the Slugger looks rather sodden as if he didn't take much exercise and ate too much tuft. Oh, no. That's shocking scenes. So the story behind the story is that this is written by a guy called Thomas Hughes.
而且“重击手”块头很大。是的。绝对是，你知道，迈克·泰森之类的。但“重击手”看起来相当臃肿，好像他不怎么锻炼，吃得太多了。哦，不。真是令人震惊的场面。所以故事背后的故事是，这是由一个叫托马斯·休斯的人写的。
Thomas Hughes, you would love Thomas Hughes, Tom. He's a fascinating man. He himself had been a pupil at rugby school. He went on to become a lawyer and a liberal MP. And would you believe he tried to set up a kind of utopian society in Tennessee? Did you know this? God, so many of our people are doing it. Ignatius Donnelly, who wrote about Atlantis, did something very similar, didn't he?
托马斯·休斯，你会喜欢托马斯·休斯的，汤姆。他是个迷人的人。他本人曾是拉格比公学的学生。他后来成为了一名律师和自由党议员。你敢相信吗？他试图在田纳西州建立一个乌托邦社会。你知道这个吗？天哪，我们的人里有好多都在做这种事。写过亚特兰蒂斯的伊格内修斯·唐纳利，也做过非常类似的事情，不是吗？
He did. So Thomas Hughes tried to set up a utopian society in Tennessee with its own library in croquet lawn and newspaper. But not cricket pitch. But do you know what he called it, Tom? No. Rugby Tennessee. Rugby Tennessee.
他做过。所以托马斯·休斯试图在田纳西州建立一个乌托邦社会，有自己的图书馆、槌球场和报纸。但没有板球场。但你知道他叫它什么吗，汤姆？不知道。拉格比，田纳西州。拉格比，田纳西州。
Brilliant. And he was a great enthusiast for muscular Christianity. So this idea that you would teach Christian principles and kind of sporting prowess side by side, a healthy mind and a healthy body. And Thomas Hughes would tour the land, not just the land, but he would go up specifically to northern towns, the kind of towns actually that ended up having football clubs later on, kind of Premier League championship football clubs. He would go up there and preach the gospel, not just of Christianity, but of sport. And that's, of course, why I think sport is such a
太棒了。他还是“肌肉基督教”的狂热支持者。所以这个理念是，你会同时教授基督教原则和体育竞技能力，健康的头脑和健康的身体。托马斯·休斯会巡回全国，不仅是全国，他还会专门去北部城镇，那些后来有了足球俱乐部的城镇，那种英超冠军足球俱乐部。他会去那里传福音，不仅是基督教的福音，还有体育的福音。当然，这就是为什么我认为体育是如此
major part and sport as forming character. Well, so many of the earliest football teams derive from churches. One thinks of Aston Villa, for instance. Yes. Founded by Methodists. Wolves, my team, I think was founded by a church. Everton was founded by a church. Sports and religion were very, very closely interwoven in the 19th century. It's thanks to the preaching of people like Thomas Hughes. It doesn't seem to me that it's about becoming too much of a Christian. It's also about becoming a decent chap.
重要的部分，体育作为塑造性格的手段。嗯，最早的许多足球队都源于教堂。人们会想到阿斯顿维拉，例如。是的。由卫理公会教徒创立。狼队，我的球队，我想也是由教堂创立的。埃弗顿是由教堂创立的。体育和宗教在19世纪紧密交织在一起。这要归功于像托马斯·休斯这样的人的布道。在我看来，这不仅仅是关于成为一个虔诚的基督徒。这也是关于成为一个正派的人。
Yes, it is. Absolutely. And the key about Tom Brown is right from the beginning, he is a decent chap. So Scud East, when he meets him, says, this is on his first day, a great deal depends on how a fellow cuts up at first. If he's got nothing odd about him and answers straightforward and holds his head up, he gets on. And that is basically the kind of ideal that underruns all of it, that you don't want to be actually too brilliant at anything. This is Harry Potter, Tom. Harry Potter want to be actually too brilliant at anything. This is Harry Potter, Tom.
是的，确实。绝对是。关于汤姆·布朗的关键在于，从一开始，他就是一个正派的人。所以斯库德·伊斯特在见到他时说，这是在他第一天，一个人最初的表现非常重要。如果他没有什么奇怪的地方，回答直截了当，昂首挺胸，他就能相处得很好。这基本上就是贯穿这一切的理想，你不想在任何事情上表现得太出色。这就是哈利·波特，汤姆。哈利·波特不想在任何事情上表现得太出色。这就是哈利·波特，汤姆。
Harry Potter is actually, he's not especially academic. He is brilliant at sports. He's extraordinarily gifted at Quidditch. We'll come on to talk about Quidditch. Cock of the school is the slang in Tom Brown's school days for chief jock. Yes. Cock of the school is probably not a nickname you would welcome now at a British public school, is it? Well, and another expostulation, which is what the senior boys say to the young boys is, you young muff. And of course, shall I tell you how Tom Brown is described? Do. And this
哈利·波特实际上，他并不是特别擅长学术。他擅长体育。他在魁地奇方面非常有天赋。我们稍后会谈到魁地奇。“学校之王”是《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》中对头号运动员的俚语。是的。“学校之王”可能不是你现在在英国公立学校会受欢迎的绰号，是吗？嗯，还有另一种抗议，也就是高年级学生对低年级学生说的，你这个小笨蛋。当然，我要告诉你汤姆·布朗是怎么被描述的吗？说吧。而这
will be particularly shocking to our American listeners. The most reckless young scapegrace among the fags. Yes. So fagging is a really important part of school stories. Do you want to explain what fags are for our American listeners? A younger boy will act as basically a servant to an older boy, and they'll be assigned to the older boy as his fag. That means they will have to bring him toast. They'll have to shine his shoes. They'll have to do errands for him, carry messages,
对我们的美国听众来说会特别令人震惊。所有“勤杂工”中最鲁莽的年轻淘气鬼。是的。“勤杂工”是校园故事中非常重要的一部分。你想为我们的美国听众解释一下什么是“勤杂工”吗？一个低年级的男孩基本上会充当高年级男孩的仆人，他们会被分配给高年级男孩作为他的“勤杂工”。这意味着他们必须给他拿吐司。他们必须擦亮他的鞋子。他们必须为他跑腿，传话，
all of these kinds of things. So fagging, yes, our American listeners will find this hilarious because of the connotations of the word, but fagging persisted in British schools until after the Second World War and then was eventually phased out. So Tom Brown is very obviously the template for Harry Potter. He's a slightly bland, but generally decent and admirable boy who goes through this rite of passage to make him a man through a series of trials. But the other thing, of course, is that a key part of Tom Brown's school days is the influence of the headmaster. So you mentioned Dumbledore. Dumbledore is a huge figure in
所有这些事情。所以“勤杂工”，是的，我们的美国听众会觉得这很滑稽，因为这个词的内涵，但“勤杂工”制度在英国学校一直持续到二战后，然后最终被逐步淘汰。所以汤姆·布朗显然是哈利·波特的模板。他是一个稍微平庸，但总体上正派且令人钦佩的男孩，他通过一系列考验经历了这种成年礼，使他成为一个男人。但另一件事，当然，是《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》的关键部分是校长的影响。所以你提到了邓布利多。邓布利多是一个巨大的人物，在
Harry Potter. It's Gandalf Merlin-like figure who is the headmaster of the school. And Tom Brown's school days has its own Dumbledore in a character called Dr. Arnold, a real life person. So the person who had been Thomas Hughes's headmaster. Dr. Arnold lived from 1795 to 1842. He was head of rugby from 1828 to 1841. And he really, do you think I'm exaggerating, Tom, when I say he's one of the absolute founding fathers of the Victorian age, the Victorian ethos? No, not at all.
《哈利·波特》中。他是甘道夫、梅林式的人物，是学校的校长。《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》有它自己的邓布利多，一个叫阿诺德博士的角色，一个现实生活中的人。所以那个曾是托马斯·休斯校长的人。阿诺德博士生活在1795年到1842年。他从1828年到1841年担任拉格比公学的校长。汤姆，你觉得我夸张了吗，当我说他是维多利亚时代、维多利亚精神的绝对奠基人之一时？不，一点也不。
I mean, he is absolutely a towering figure, isn't he? And influential, as you said earlier on, not just on Britain, but on the ideals of sport and manliness and all that kind of thing that the British Empire exports. Yeah. So he becomes a myth, Dr. Arnold. So for those people who are listening to this podcast and think, well, this is two public school boys talking about public schools and they think this is terribly interesting, but it's not very important to anybody else. Dr. Arnold would have been a name recognisable to almost any educated person. Certainly in Britain and beyond Britain, actually, his influence was carried into the colonies, into the United States and so on. Because Baron de Coubertin is directly influenced by his example in setting up the Olympics, isn't he? He carried with him Tom Brown's school days. And he said, what Dr. Arnold did at rugby school is one of the great transformations in all cultural history. Coubertin was obsessed with Thomas Arnold, as so many people were. How does he have this stature?
我的意思是，他绝对是一个高耸的人物，不是吗？而且正如你之前所说，不仅对英国有影响力，而且对大英帝国输出的体育和男子气概等理想也有影响力。是的。所以阿诺德博士变成了一个神话。所以对于那些正在听这个播客并认为，嗯，这是两个公立学校男孩在谈论公立学校，他们认为这非常有趣，但对其他人来说并不重要的人。阿诺德博士的名字几乎任何受过教育的人都会认出来。当然在英国，甚至在英国之外，实际上，他的影响被带到了殖民地，带到了美国等等。因为顾拜旦男爵在创办奥运会时直接受到了他的榜样的影响，不是吗？他随身带着《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》。他说，阿诺德博士在拉格比公学所做的事情是所有文化史上最伟大的变革之一。顾拜旦痴迷于托马斯·阿诺德，就像许多人一样。他怎么会有这样的地位？
I mean, you know, a head of a school. I mean, it seems an odd. Yeah. You couldn't imagine that happening now. Arnold had been himself educated as a boarding school at Winchester, arguably the first true public school, which we'll talk about much later on. Arnold himself, on his first night at Winchester, which you believe, Tom, he had knelt and prayed by his bedside and he'd been physically attacked by the other boys for doing so, which is very
我的意思是，你知道，一个学校的校长。我的意思是，这看起来很奇怪。是的。你无法想象现在会发生这种情况。阿诺德本人曾在温彻斯特的一所寄宿学校接受教育，可以说是第一所真正的公立学校，我们稍后会详细讨论。阿诺德本人，在温彻斯特的第一晚，你敢相信吗，汤姆，他跪在床边祈祷，结果被其他男孩因为这样做而身体攻击，这非常
heartening. Was he tossed in a blanket? Yeah, roasted over a fire. Arnold became one of the great kind of advocates of political liberalism and anglicanism broad church anglicanism in the middle of the 19th century he's appointed to that to be head of rugby school in 1828 he almost quintuples the number of boys at the school and he has this extraordinary project which now i into some degree, I think, because so many schools are not just private schools, bear Arnold's imprint. We take for granted, but the time was truly radical. He argued that schools should be laboratories to turn out little Christian men, and that the
令人心寒。他被扔进毯子里了吗？是的，在火上烤。阿诺德成为了19世纪中期政治自由主义和圣公会、广教会圣公会的主要倡导者之一。他于1828年被任命为拉格比公学的校长。他几乎使学校的男孩人数增加了五倍，他有一个非凡的计划，现在我……在某种程度上，我认为，因为许多学校不仅仅是私立学校，都带有阿诺德的印记。我们认为理所当然，但在当时是真正激进的。他主张学校应该成为培养小基督徒男人的实验室，而且
important thing in school was not to fill your mind with stuff, with education. It was to form your character, your moral character. So he says, his first comment on being appointed to the headmaster of rugby, he said, my object will be, if possible, to form Christian men. And in his book, Tom Brown's School Days, Thomas Hughes writes of the tall gallant form, the kindling eye, the voice now soft as the low notes of a flute, now clear and stirring as the call of the light infantry bugle of him who stood there Sunday after Sunday, witnessing and pleading for his Lord. And this idea that the headmaster
学校里重要的事情不是用东西填满你的头脑，不是教育。而是塑造你的性格，你的道德品质。所以他说，他被任命为拉格比校长后的第一条评论，他说，我的目标将是，如果可能的话，培养基督徒男人。在他的书《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》中，托马斯·休斯写道：高大勇敢的身影，闪烁的眼睛，声音时而像长笛的低音一样柔和，时而像轻步兵号角声一样清晰而激动人心，那个星期天复星期天站在那里，见证并为他的主辩护的人。这个理念，即学校的校长
of the school was going to become this kind of great, almost this evangelist, this idea of Christian manhood. And he would send out legions of boys to be Christian men to govern Britain and its empire. This absolutely caught the imagination of the Victorians. So Arnold was an inspirational figure. And the interesting thing about him is, when Harry arrives at Hogwarts, he's already been told that there is this sort of, this undercurrent of danger in the character of Voldemort, who is the Dark Lord, and there's the dark arts, and there's this kind of evil. But Arnold absolutely believed this. I mean, he didn't call it Voldemort. For him, it was sin. So he thought that all teenage boys were threatened by sin. And actually, to be a teenage boy was kind of sinful in itself.
将成为这种伟大的人物，几乎是这种传道者，这种基督教男子气概的理念。他会派出成群的男孩去成为基督徒男人，去治理英国及其帝国。这绝对抓住了维多利亚时代人的想象力。所以阿诺德是一个鼓舞人心的人物。关于他有趣的一点是，当哈利到达霍格沃茨时，他已经被告知有一种，这种潜在的危险，在伏地魔这个角色的性格中，他是黑魔王，有黑魔法，有这种邪恶。但阿诺德绝对相信这一点。我的意思是，他没有称之为伏地魔。对他来说，那是罪。所以他认为所有的十几岁男孩都受到罪的威胁。实际上，作为一个十几岁的男孩本身就是一种罪。
So he said there are six sins endemic among schoolboys, profligacy, falsehood, cruelty, disobedience, idleness, and the bond of evil. I thought there was going to be another sin. Go on, Tom. I know the way your mind works. To which teenage boys were particularly prone. No. So people don't care about this in the 1840s. I know what you're thinking. You're thinking about teenage boys being beastly, aren't you? I'm thinking of onanism and beastliness. Don't worry. You'll get your beastliness. Okay. But you aren't worried about beastliness at this stage because they're not over-obsessed with sexuality. So for Arnold, it's more amorphous than that. It's telling lies and
所以他说有六种罪在男校学生中流行：放荡、虚伪、残忍、不服从、懒惰和邪恶的纽带。我以为会有另一种罪。继续，汤姆。我知道你的思维方式。十几岁男孩特别容易犯的罪。不。所以人们在19世纪40年代并不关心这个。我知道你在想什么。你在想十几岁男孩变得禽兽不如，对吧？我在想手淫和禽兽行为。别担心。你会得到你的禽兽行为的。好吧。但你在这个阶段并不担心禽兽行为，因为他们并没有过度沉迷于性。所以对阿诺德来说，它比那更模糊。那是撒谎和
not doing your bit and cheating and all these kinds of things. And he believes that life is a constant struggle to overcome this sin. And this is obviously what lots of Christians believe. And that he can guide the boys towards a sort of higher state. And the way he would do that is through a character called Percy Weasley. Do you know the Harry Potter books very well, Tom? Do you know who Percy Weasley is? I can't, they all blur. So Percy Weasley is Ron Weasley's older brother. And at the beginning of the book, he's introduced to us, Harry's cashing the train and the Weasleys are there. And the Weasleys are all giving Percy a bit of grief because he's actually going to be a prefect. And Arnold wanted to use the prefect system. So being a prefect is very important. So being a prefect is being a senior boy who acts as a kind of conduit between the headmaster and the other boys. There had always
不尽职和作弊以及所有这些事情。他相信生活是一场克服这种罪的持续斗争。这显然是许多基督徒所相信的。他可以引导男孩们走向一种更高的状态。他这样做的方式是通过一个叫珀西·韦斯莱的角色。汤姆，你很了解《哈利·波特》的书吗？你知道珀西·韦斯莱是谁吗？我不能，它们都模糊了。所以珀西·韦斯莱是罗恩·韦斯莱的哥哥。在书的开头，他被介绍给我们，哈利在火车站，韦斯莱一家在那里。韦斯莱一家都在给珀西一点难堪，因为他实际上要成为一名级长。阿诺德想使用级长制度。所以成为一名级长非常重要。所以成为一名级长就是成为一名高年级男孩，他充当校长和其他男孩之间的某种渠道。一直都有
been prefects. So in the 14th century, when Winchester College was set up, there were prefects there, senior boys who kind of represent the boys. Derived from Merton College at Oxford. Exactly. Yes. Arnold's idea was that the prefects would actually now be, instead of leading revolts against the headmaster, they would be working for him. And he calls them, or his disciples call them an aristocracy of talent and worth. So the prefects would dine with Arnold and they would sort of marshal the other boys and lead them towards better behavior. So a question then, to go to a public school, you have to pay for it. That's why they're called public. They're open to everybody who can afford it. Who can afford it, yeah. So by definition, people who go to these public schools are from the elites. Is Arnold
级长。所以14世纪，当温彻斯特学院成立时，那里就有级长，高年级男孩代表男孩们。源于牛津大学的默顿学院。正是如此。是的。阿诺德的想法是，级长现在实际上将不再是领导反对校长的叛乱，而是为他工作。他称他们，或者他的追随者称他们为“天赋与价值的贵族”。所以级长会和阿诺德一起用餐，他们会某种程度上组织其他男孩，引导他们走向更好的行为。那么一个问题，去公立学校，你必须付钱。这就是为什么它们被称为“公立”。它们对所有付得起钱的人开放。付得起钱的人，是的。所以根据定义，去这些公立学校的人来自精英阶层。阿诺德
self-consciously training them to go out and govern Britain and to govern various parts of the world that have been painted pink? Is that an idea that he is training a moral elite? I don't think it's an obsession for Arnold, but it becomes an obsession for, as it were, the myth of Arnold. So Arnold himself is not, I think, as interested in the empire as his successors are. Not looking at the empire then, just looking at Britain. Is he thinking, it's important that I do this, not just for the sake of the souls of the individual boys, but for the good of the entire country the individual boys, but for the good of the entire country. Oh yeah, undoubtedly. Undoubtedly, all public school headmasters
是否自觉地训练他们去治理英国，去治理被涂成粉红色的世界各地？这是一个他正在训练道德精英的理念吗？我不认为这对阿诺德来说是一种痴迷，但它成为了，可以说，阿诺德神话的痴迷。所以阿诺德本人，我认为，对帝国并不像他的继任者那样感兴趣。当时没有看帝国，只是看着英国。他在想，我这样做很重要，不仅是为了个别男孩的灵魂，也是为了整个国家的利益。哦，是的，毫无疑问。毫无疑问，所有的公立学校校长
are conscious that they are training an elite of boys who are going to become cabinet ministers, churchmen. I mean, if you look at the kind of people who go to public schools in the 18th and 19th centuries, they all go on to become generals, to become the governors of colonies, to become MPs, all of these kinds of things. Absolutely, they do. So in Harry Potter, Dumbledore has a host of kind of disciples. They call themselves Dumbledore's army, the people who kind of worship Dumbledore, who want to carry on his example. So does Arnold. So the heads of schools like Marlborough and Harrow, the headmaster of producer Jack's
都意识到他们正在训练一群将成为内阁大臣、教会人士的精英男孩。我的意思是，如果你看看18世纪和19世纪去公立学校的人，他们都继续成为将军，成为殖民地的总督，成为议员，所有这些事情。绝对，他们是。所以在《哈利·波特》中，邓布利多有一群追随者。他们称自己为“邓布利多军”，那些崇拜邓布利多的人，那些想要延续他榜样的人。阿诺德也是如此。所以像马尔伯勒和哈罗这样的学校校长，杰克母校的校长，伯明翰的爱德华国王学校，他是阿诺德的追随者。这些人走出去，在接下来的50年左右，他们创造了这种阿诺德式学校的制度。所以英国几乎每一所学校，英国每一所私立学校都忠于阿诺德的精神。还有文法学校，也是。所以为海外听众解释一下，文法学校对所有人开放，但你必须通过考试才能进入。是的。所以文法学校会在一个小镇上。莎士比亚上过文法学校。它们最初是为了教授拉丁语，但你并不一定在文法学校寄宿。
old school, King Edward's Birmingham, he was a disciple of Arnold's. And these people go out and for the next 50 years or so, they create this kind of regime of Arnoldian schools. So almost every school in Britain, every private school in Britain is true to Arnold's ethos. And grammar schools, right, as well. So to explain for overseas listeners, grammar schools are open to everybody, but you have to get in on basis of exams. Yes. So grammar schools will be in a small town. Shakespeare went to a grammar school. They were initially set up to teach really Latin, but you're not necessarily boarding as a grammar
嗯，你不在文法学校寄宿。但文法学校越来越模仿文法学校。嗯，你不在文法学校寄宿。但文法学校越来越模仿拉格比的样子。哦，绝对是。级长。在本集的下半部分，我们将浏览《哈利·波特》故事的许多方面，体育、寄宿学院，并谈论这些的历史。学校，不仅在英国，而且在世界各地，都在复制他们所看到的阿诺德公式。而他们从哪里得到阿诺德公式的呢，就是从《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》。所以它出版了，正如我们所说，在1857年。它在
school. Well, you're not boarding as a grammar school. But the grammar schools increasingly kind of ape the grammar school. Well, you're not boarding as a grammar school. But the grammar schools increasingly kind of ape the rugby look. Oh, absolutely they do. Prefects. In the second half of this episode, we're going to go through lots of the aspects of the Harry Potter stories, the sport, the boarding houses, and talk about the history of those. Schools, not just in Britain, but across the world, copy what they see as Arnold's formula. And where they're getting Arnold's formula from is from Tom Brown's school days. So it came out, as we said, in 1857. It sold 11,000 copies in
第一年卖出了11,000册。它在35年内经历了52个版本。你已经提到了皮埃尔·德·顾拜旦。他谈到了托马斯·阿诺德这个强大的人物，他那无与伦比的工作的辉煌轮廓。我的意思是，顾拜旦绝对痴迷于阿诺德，正如我们所说。再举两个例子让你感受一下巨大的影响。第一，1911年，所以这是在英国建立了当时并不存在的公立学校之后。1911年，英国教育委员会建议英国的每一所学校都必须在图书馆里有一本《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》，作为学生的榜样。另一个例子，在印度建立的最具影响力的寄宿学校之一，即拉杰库马尔学院，成立于1870年。那所学校的校长过去常读，汤姆，你会高兴的，板球片段
its first year. It has been through 52 editions within about 35 years. You mentioned Pierre de Coubertin already. He talked to the powerful figure of Thomas Arnold, the glorious contour of his incomparable work. I mean, de Coubert is absolutely obsessed with Arnold, as we said. Just two more examples to give you a sense of the massive impact. One, 1911, so this is after Britain has set up state schools, which at this point didn't exist. In 1911, the British Board of Education recommended that every single school in Britain must have a copy of Tom Brown's School Days in its library as an example to the pupils. The other example, one of the first most influential boarding school set up in India, which is Rajkumar College, founded in 1870. The headmaster of that school used to read out, Tom, it will please you, the cricketing passages
来自《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》，在学校集会上代替基督教布道，因为他认为这会更好地影响男孩们成为正直的绅士。我读到《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》在日本被使用，在日本向世界开放并试图学习英语之后。男孩们会被要求把《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》翻译成日语，但他们会省略板球比赛的细节，因为那太具有挑战性了。真的吗？我看不出来。所以这就是日本出错的地方。所以《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》，在本集这一半的最后几分钟，
from Tom Brown School Days at school assemblies instead of Christian sermons, because he thought it would better influence the boys to become upstanding gentlemen. I was reading that Tom Brown school days was used in Japan after the Japanese had opened up to the world and were trying to learn English. Boys would be set to translate Tom Brown school days into Japanese, but they would omit the detail of the cricket match because that was too challenging. That's really? I couldn't see that. So that's where Japan went wrong. So Tom Brown's School Days, just the last few minutes of this half of the episode,
《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》成为了许多故事的模板，我认为，这些故事是1860年到1950年或1960年左右，对英国儿童，实际上对更广泛的英国环境中的儿童影响最大的故事。这些是校园故事，它们非常、非常受欢迎。所以这方面最著名的例子是《男孩自己的报纸》（Boys' Own Paper）。《男孩自己的报纸》，我们仍然在谈论，不是吗，在英国，关于“男孩自己的故事”，关于勇气和胆识的故事。《男孩自己的报纸》卖出了25万份，每一份大约有四个孩子阅读。所以它的读者群大约是一百万。非凡。奇怪的是，它被那些根本没有机会去常春藤覆盖的哥特式公立学校的孩子们阅读。
Tom Brown's School Days becomes the template for a host of stories that are, I would argue, by far the most influential stories on children in Britain, and indeed in the British environment more broadly, between, let's say, 1860 and 1950 or 1960 or so. And these are the school stories that are colossally, colossally popular. So the most famous examples of this in something like the Boys' Own Paper. The Boys' Own Paper, we still talk, don't we, in Britain, of Boys' Own Stories, stories of pluck and daring do. The Boys' Own Paper sold a quarter of a million copies, and each copy was read by about four children. So its readership was about one million. Extraordinary. And the weird thing about that is that it's being read by children who have no prospect of going to an ivy-clad Gothic public school.
是的，我发现这绝对迷人。所以体现校园故事的另外两份伟大的出版物是《磁铁》（The Magnet）和《宝石》（The Gem）。所以这些是男孩报纸。顺便说一句，它们也被女孩阅读，并且有女孩的对应版本。它们在1900年代、1910年代、1920年代。乔治·奥威尔写了一篇关于它们的精彩文章，关于校园故事及其影响。在其中连载的最著名的故事系列是关于校园故事及其影响的格雷弗莱尔斯（Greyfriars）。在其中连载的最著名的故事系列是格雷弗莱尔斯校园故事，由比利·邦特主演。这些故事被来自社会各阶层的人阅读。正如你所说，汤姆，
Yeah, I find this absolutely fascinating. So the other two great publications that sort of embodied the school story were The Magnet and The Gem. So these were boys' papers. By the way, they are read by girls and there are girls' equivalents of them. And they are in the 1900s, 1910s, 1920s. George Orwell wrote a brilliant essay about them, about school stories and about their influence. The most famous series of stories that run in them are the Greyf, about school stories and about their influence. The most famous series of stories that run in them are the Grave for Eyes school stories starring Billy Bunter. And those stories are read by people from all across the social spectrum. As you say, Tom,
它们的读者中，永远不会踏入寄宿学校10英里范围内的人，比寄宿学校的男孩多得多。而且它们在殖民地被阅读，不是吗？所以我想到C.L.R.詹姆斯，伟大的马克思主义板球历史学家，虽然没有足够的马克思主义板球历史学家，但他深受它们的影响。我的意思是，他受到马克思的影响，也受到托马斯·休斯的影响。这是一种如此奇怪的融合。我很高兴你提到了C.L.R.詹姆斯。所以C.L.R.詹姆斯上了一所叫皇后皇家学院的学校，在西班牙港。他可以说是加勒比地区，嗯，加勒比地区有史以来最伟大的知识分子之一。他那本精彩的书《黑雅各宾》，正如你所说，伟大的马克思主义历史学家，伟大的板球作家。在他的自传《超越边界》中，他谈到了托马斯·阿诺德的遗产。他说，教育和文化史上最奇妙的变革之一。他说，关于他从校园故事中得到的男子气概、正派、公平竞争、团队精神的准则，他说，从八年的学校生活中，这个准则成为了我存在的道德框架。它从未离开过我。我小时候学过它。我作为一个男人遵守了它，
they have far more readers who will never, ever go within 10 miles of a boarding school than they are boarding school boys. And they're being read in the colonies, aren't they? So I think of C.L.R. James, the great Marxist historian of cricket, and there aren't enough Marxist historians of cricket, but he was hugely influenced by them in his approach. I mean, he's influenced by Marx, and he's influenced by Thomas Hughes. It's such a weird blend. I'm glad you mentioned C.L.R. James. So C.L.R. James went to a school called Queen's Royal College in Port of Spain. He's arguably the greatest intellectual that the
现在我再也无法嘲笑它了。这是一种如此奇怪的融合，不是吗？激励他成年生活的马克思主义似乎绝对与那种公立学校精神融合在一起了。是的。所以汤姆，在我们进入休息之前，许多听这个节目的年轻人会以同样的喜爱回想起《哈利·波特》的故事。托马斯·休斯在《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》中说，他写它是为了获得布道的机会。而《哈利·波特》的故事是相当爱说教的书。所以每一本书提供的道德教训。J.K.罗琳所做的根本没有任何前所未有的事情。而且中间有很多故事，校园故事，做了完全一样的事情。
Caribbean, well, one of the greatest intellectuals that the Caribbean ever produced. His brilliant book, The Black Jacobin, as you say, great Marxist historian, great writer on cricket. And in his autobiography, Beyond a Boundary, he talks about Thomas Arnold's legacy. And he says, one of the most fantastic transformations in the history of education and of culture. And he says of the code of kind of manliness, decency, fair play, team spirit that he got from the school stories, he says, from the eight years of school life, this code became the moral framework of my existence. It has never left me. I learned it as a boy. I have obeyed it as a man,
所以格雷弗莱尔斯的故事，例如，哈里·沃顿和他的朋友们的故事。所以我们将谈论它们，顺便说一句。我痴迷于这些故事，正如你所知。我绝对痴迷。我做到了。我将在我们为《历史余韵》俱乐部成员准备的加更节目中更多地谈论它们，
and now I can no longer laugh at it. It's such an odd fusion, isn't it? The Marxism that inspired him throughout his adult life seems absolutely to have interfused with that public school spirit. Yeah. So Tom, just before we go into the break, lots of the younger people listening to this will think back with similar fondness, I would say, to the Harry Potter stories. Thomas Hughes said at Tom Brown School Days that he wrote it to get the chance of preaching. And the Harry Potter stories are quite preachy books. So the moral lessons that each book kind of provides. J.K. Rowling was doing nothing unprecedented at all. And there were lots of stories in between, school stories that did exactly the same thing.
该节目将在明天或周三播出。所以如果你不是《历史余韵》俱乐部的成员，并且渴望听到我谈论比利·邦特。那个被开除的胖猫头鹰。那个被开除的胖猫头鹰。这是你的机会。所以这些故事对工人阶级儿童产生了巨大的影响。在他那本精彩的书《英国工人阶级的知识生活》中，伟大的历史学家乔纳森·罗斯，有大量令人难以置信的普通人发现这些故事的例子，它们的对应物，这些是他们的圣经。他们从这些故事中汲取了他们的道德准则。我给你举两个例子。
So the Greyfriars stories, for example, the stories of Harry Wharton and his friends. So we will be talking about them, by the way. I'm obsessed by these stories, as you know. I'm absolutely obsessed. I do. And I will be talking more about them in our bonus episode for Rest Is History Club members,
比如格雷弗莱尔的故事，也就是哈利·沃顿和他的朋友们的故事。顺便说一下，我们将会谈到他们。如你所知，我痴迷于这些故事。我绝对是痴迷。确实如此。我会在我们“历史余韵俱乐部”会员的加更节目中更多地谈论它们，
which will be out either tomorrow or Wednesday. So if you are not a member of the Rest Is History Club and you pine to hear me talking about Billy Bunter. The fat owl of the removed. The fat owl of the removed. This is your chance. So these stories were enormously influential on working class children. In his brilliant book, The Intellectual Life of the English Working Classes, Jonathan Rose, great historian, has loads of examples of incredibly implausible people who found these stories, their equivalent, these were their Bible. They drew their moral code from these stories. I'll give you two examples.
该节目将于明天或周三发布。所以，如果你还不是“历史余韵俱乐部”的会员，又渴望听到我谈论比利·邦特——那只“移除学校的胖猫头鹰”，那只“移除学校的胖猫头鹰”——这就是你的机会。这些故事对工人阶级的孩子们影响巨大。伟大的历史学家乔纳森·罗斯在他那本精彩的著作《英国工人阶级的知识生活》中，列举了大量令人难以置信的例子，这些人视这些故事及其同类作品为圣经。他们从这些故事中汲取道德准则。我给你举两个例子。
One, a boy growing up in the South Wales coalfield called a Nairn Bevan, the founder of our beloved National Health Service, Tom. And Nairn Bevan worked as a butcher's boy. And he would go to the newsagent every week to pick up his copies of The Magnet and The Gem, full of boarding school stories. His father, a miner, banned them from the house. This was very common. Because they were seen as being badly written or because the kind of moral lessons were disapproved of? Often parents would regard the misbehaviour of boys in the story.
第一，一个在南威尔士煤矿区长大的男孩，名叫奈恩·贝文，是我们敬爱的国民保健署的创始人，汤姆。奈恩·贝文曾做过屠夫学徒。他每周都会去报刊亭买《磁铁》和《宝石》杂志，里面全是寄宿学校的故事。他父亲是个矿工，禁止这些书进家门。这很常见。是因为它们被认为写得烂，还是因为其中的道德教训不被认可？父母们通常会关注故事中男孩们的恶作剧。
Stealing jam, fighting, falling out of windows, wrestling with tramps and footpads. Isn't that what Billy Bunter says when he's being caned? Yes, when he's being beaten by Mr. Quelch. For stealing jam. Always stealing jam. Or other boys' hampers. So lots of parents would ban them. They said, you should read something better. Mr. Quelch. For stealing jam. Always stealing jam. Or other boys' hampers, Tom. So lots of parents would ban them.
偷果酱、打架、从窗户掉下来、与流浪汉和扒手扭打。比利·邦特挨鞭子时不是这么说的吗？是的，当他被奎尔奇先生殴打时。因为偷果酱。总是偷果酱。或者偷其他男孩的零食篮。所以很多父母会禁止这些书。他们说，你应该读点更好的。奎尔奇先生。因为偷果酱。总是偷果酱。或者偷其他男孩的零食篮，汤姆。所以很多父母会禁止这些书。
They said, you should read something better. You should read something more improving. Bevan would sneak out and buy them anyway, and he hid them under a railway bridge near his house. I mean, it's extraordinary that somebody who is thought of as being one of the absolute titans of socialism did this. And the other example is a great working class historian called Robert Roberts, who grew up in Salford and wrote a book about it called The Classic Slum. He said, for boys like him, he said, grey friars became for us our true alma mater,
他们说，你应该读点更好的。你应该读点更有启发性的。贝文还是会偷偷溜出去买，并把它们藏在屋子附近的铁路桥下。我的意思是，一个被认为是社会主义泰斗级人物的人竟然做这种事，真是不可思议。另一个例子是一位伟大的工人阶级历史学家罗伯特·罗伯茨，他在索尔福德长大，写了一本关于那里的书，叫《经典贫民窟》。他说，对于像他这样的男孩来说，格雷弗莱尔斯成了我们真正的母校，
to whom we felt bound by a dreamlike loyalty. Over the years, these simple tales conditioned whole generations of boys. The public school ethos, distorted into myth and told among us weakly in penny numbers, set our ideals and standards. And in the final estimate, it may well be found that Frank Richards, who is the author of the Greyfriars stories, had more influence on the mind and outlook of young, working class England than any other single person. Okay, well, that's brilliant, Dominic. I think that you've absolutely shown that there is a living link between Tom Brown's school days
我们对它怀有一种梦幻般的忠诚。多年来，这些简单的故事塑造了整整一代男孩。公学精神被扭曲成神话，以廉价小说的形式在我们中间流传，确立了我们的理想和标准。最终，人们很可能会发现，格雷弗莱尔斯故事的作者弗兰克·理查兹对英国年轻工人阶级思想和观念的影响，比任何其他个人都要大。好吧，多米尼克，这太精彩了。我认为你已经充分证明了《汤姆·布朗的学校时代》与《哈利·波特》之间存在着活生生的联系，
and Harry Potter, and people can see how that thread would have been woven through 150 years or more of British popular culture. When we come back, we will look at how all the famous elements in the Harry Potter stories are prefigured in the Victorian public school. listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome to Hogwarts, said Professor McGonagall. The start of term banquet will begin shortly. But before you take your seats in the Great Hall, you'll be sorted into your hooses. The sorting is a very important ceremony because while you're here, your hoose will be something like your family within Hogwarts. You will have classes with the rest of your hoose, sleep in your hoose dormitory and spend free time in your hoose common room. The four hooses are called Gryffindor, Hufflepuff, Ravenclaw, and Slytherin.
人们可以看到这条线索是如何贯穿了150多年甚至更久的英国流行文化的。回来后，我们将看看《哈利·波特》故事中所有著名的元素是如何在维多利亚时代的公学中预示的。收听奖励剧集并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。就是therestisentertainment.com。欢迎来到霍格沃茨，麦格教授说。开学宴会即将开始。但在你们在礼堂就座之前，你们将被分到各自的学院。分院仪式非常重要，因为在你们待在这里期间，学院就像你们在霍格沃茨的家。你们将和同学院的人一起上课，睡在学院宿舍，并在学院公共休息室度过空闲时间。四个学院分别是格兰芬多、赫奇帕奇、拉文克劳和斯莱特林。
Each hoose has its own noble history, and each has produced outstanding witches and wizards. While you're at Hogwarts, your triumphs will earn you hoose points, while any rule-breaking will lose hoose points. At the end of the year, the hoose with the most points is awarded the Hoos Cup, a great honor. I hope each of you will be a credit to whichever Hoos becomes yours. So that, Dominic, was obviously J.K. Rowling and Professor McGonigal again from Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone. And that's Harry and his chums who've come from, what's it, Platform 9 and 3 quarters, King's Cross to Hogwarts. And this thing about houses, as we south of the border call them, what is Professor McGonagall going on about? Where she's got this idea from? Does it perhaps go back to Victorian public schools?
每个学院都有自己高贵的历史，也都培养出了杰出的男女巫师。在霍格沃茨期间，你们的成就将为学院赢得积分，而任何违反校规的行为都会扣除学院积分。学年结束时，积分最高的学院将获得学院杯，这是一项巨大的荣誉。我希望你们每个人都能为自己所属的学院争光。所以，多米尼克，那显然又是J.K.罗琳和《哈利·波特与魔法石》里的麦格教授。那是哈利和他的伙伴们，他们从什么地方，国王十字车站的9又3/4站台来到霍格沃茨。关于我们边境以南所称的“学院”，麦格教授到底在说什么？她是从哪里得到这个想法的？这是否可以追溯到维多利亚时代的公学？
It does. It does, Tom. So just before we get to the houses, one second. Harry is with his family. He gets his letter. He gets his hour. He gets all his gear. He goes off to school. In almost every element of the story, he's doing something that people in public school stories have done before. So crucially, he gets the train.
确实如此。确实如此，汤姆。所以在我们谈到学院之前，先等一下。哈利和他的家人在一起。他收到了信。他拿到了他的猫头鹰。他拿到了所有的装备。他去上学了。在故事的几乎每一个元素中，他所做的事情都是公学故事里的人以前做过的。最关键的是，他坐了火车。
So you know the Hogwarts Express. I mean, even people who haven't read Harry Potter will know about the Hogwarts Express. It goes from platform nine and three quarters at King's Cross Station. That is a well-used device in school stories because, of course, so many people did go by train to public schools. And actually, the existence of the British public school network depends on the Victorian railway system. Because often, the point of these schools is that they are on isolated moors or provincial towns a long way from the urban centres that presumably are producing the wealth that enables parents to pay for these schools. Exactly. It's precisely that point in the 19th century when people are very anxious about the
所以你知道霍格沃茨特快列车。我的意思是，即使是没读过《哈利·波特》的人也会知道霍格沃茨特快列车。它从国王十字车站的9又3/4站台出发。这是学校故事中常用的手法，因为当然，很多人确实是坐火车去公学的。实际上，英国公学网络的存在依赖于维多利亚时代的铁路系统。因为这些学校存在的意义往往在于它们位于偏远的荒原或省城，远离那些据推测创造了财富、使父母有能力支付学费的城市中心。没错。这正是19世纪人们对工业革命、城市扩张、城市中那种污浊的空气、所有工业现代性等事物感到非常焦虑的时刻，他们正在寻找逃避。这在20世纪引起了对公学的巨大批评，不是吗？这种观点认为，正是工业创造了金钱，然后被用来把这些实业家的孩子送到乡下那些中世纪的、伪中世纪的学校里。好吧，你说得完全对，汤姆，中世纪主义才是重点。英国许多伟大的公学，我所认为的英国标志性公学，实际上都是19世纪伪中世纪的产物。
consequences of the Industrial Revolution, the expansion of the city, the kind of fetid air of the cities, all of industrial modernity, all of these things, and they're looking for an escape. This is the kind of cause of great criticism for public schools, isn't it, over the 20th century? This idea that it's industry that creates the money that then gets spent on sending the children of these industrialists off to medieval, faux medieval schools in the countryside. Well, you're absolutely right, Tom, that the medievalism is the point. So many of the great public schools of England, what I regard as So many of the great public schools of England, what I regard as the totemic public schools of England, are really 19th century fake medieval
基础。如果你以我上的学校马尔文为例，它成立于1865年，位于一个温泉小镇，即使是现在你也能到达那里。它在伦敦帕丁顿火车站的铁路终点站。人们会坐火车去那里。重点是你去了乡下，把工业现代性抛在了身后。重点是你去了乡下，把工业现代性抛在了身后。学校的建筑，就像霍格沃茨（一座城堡）一样，建筑风格是中世纪哥特式的。很多学校都是这种风格。西奥，我们的制片人，正如常客们所知，西奥自称是法国人。事实上，西奥是在惠灵顿公学受的教育，该校成立于1859年，
foundations. If you take my own school that I went to, Malvern, which was founded in 1865, it's in a spa town that you get to even now. It's at the end of the railway line from London, Paddington. People would go there on the train. The point is that you're going to the countryside and you're leaving industrial modernity behind. The point is that you're going to the countryside and you're leaving industrial modernity behind. The buildings of the school, like Hogwarts, which is a castle, the buildings are done in a kind of medieval Gothic. So many schools are done in this style. Theo, our producer, so Theo, as regular listeners will know, purports to be a Frenchman. In fact, Theo was educated at Wellington College, which was set up in 1859
是为了纪念士兵的儿子们。那是用威灵顿公爵的名字命名的吗？是以威灵顿公爵命名的。现在你自己的学校，汤姆，很遗憾地说，是一个更近期的暴发户式基金会，不是吗？是1920年代的坎福德吗？好吧，那是因为我出身卑微，属于下中产阶级，多米尼克。显然，显然。但如果你看看这些学校的网站，你会发现它们大多是伪中世纪哥特式建筑，某种程度上是加权的。当然，国王十字车站也是如此。
for the Sons of Soldiers. Was that named after the Duke of Wellington? After the Duke of Wellington. Now your own school, Tom, I'm sorry to say is a much more recent Arriviste Foundation, isn't it? Isn't it 1920s Canford? Well, that's because I'm of humble, lower middle class stock, Dominic. Clearly, clearly. But so many of these schools, if you look at their websites, you will see that they are kind of mock medieval Gothic buildings, which are sort of weighted. Which, of course, King's Cross is as well.
人们认为J.K.罗琳选择国王十字车站是因为那是从伦敦去往她写作地爱丁堡的火车。但也许它那伪中世纪的风格，圣潘克拉斯车站等等，也是原因之一。你就在圣潘克拉斯车站的阴影下，有着巨大的哥特式尖顶，你要去的是另一种哥特式建筑。但学院呢？好吧，学院，你提到了学院。在19世纪之前，大多数男孩都住在非常破旧的环境中。
It was assumed that J.K. Rowling chose King's Cross because that's the train that goes to Edinburgh, where she wrote it, from London. But maybe also the fact that it's cod medieval, St. Pancras and all that, is part of it as well. You're in the shadow, St. Pancras and all that is part of it as well. You're in the shadow of St. Pancras with the kind of huge Gothic spires of St. Pancras, and you're going to another kind of Gothic-ish building. But what about houses? Well, houses, you mentioned houses. Before the 19th century, most boys had kind of boarded in very ramshackle
他们可能都住在一个房间里。他们可能睡在教室里。他们可能住在校长的房子里。但学院的意义在于，阿诺德博士和他的模仿者们想要一个纪律更严明、更军事化的系统，这将使……你说是军事化。我的意思是，大概就像军团一样。字面上，完全正确。
kind of surroundings. They might've all stayed in one. They might have slept in the schoolroom. They might have stayed in the headmaster's house. But the point of houses is that Dr. Arnold and his imitators want a much more disciplined regimented system, which will institutionalize- And you say regimented. I mean, presumably literally like regiments. Literally, exactly.
字面上，就像霍格沃茨一样。霍格沃茨被分为四个相互竞争的学院。所以竞争精神被内置在学校里。这是一个19世纪的想法，即你要教给男孩们团队精神，这对于阿诺德的愿景、对于维多利亚时代统治阶级的整个精神，当然还有《哈利·波特》的精神来说都是绝对核心的，即个人永远不会比团队更重要，
Literally, as Hogwarts is. Hogwarts is divided into four competing houses. So the spirit of competition is divided into four competing houses. So the spirit of competition is built into the school. This was a 19th century idea that you will teach the boys team spirit, absolutely central
最重要的是集体，而不是你个人的得失。而学院就是这种精神的体现。关于学院的另一件事是，学院由一系列极其复杂的规则管理，外人觉得完全无法理解。而这种不可理解性正是重点所在。这种不可理解性正是重点所在。在维多利亚时代的学校里，这种情况一直持续到20世纪末，你会学习学校的规则和学校的特殊语言，两周后你会接受测试。如果你没通过，你就会被殴打，你知道，或者以某种方式受到惩罚。现在，哈利刚到的时候，你知道，他像其他人一样紧张，他被告知并被迫学习学校的规则。
to Arnold's vision, to the entire ethos of the kind of Victorian ruling classes, and of course, to the ethos of Harry Potter, that the individual is never bigger than the team,
他在格兰芬多的同龄人，他的学院以及格兰芬多的高年级学生正在指导低年级学生，并向他们解释运动规则等等。另一件事，霍格沃茨没有的一件事，这是维多利亚时代公学军事化的一部分，维多利亚时代公学的军事化伴随着一种情感克制的崇拜，即不暴露你的情绪。我的意思是，这的重要性在于——不因为想家而哭泣。没错。这是自律。但这不仅仅是一种克服思乡之情的方法。我的意思是，阿诺德阴影下的维多利亚时代教师们认为，
that the most important thing is the collective rather than your own personal gain. And the house is the kind of embodiment of that. The other thing about the house, the house is governed by an incredibly complicated series of rules that an outsider finds utterly impenetrable and impossible to understand. And the impenetrability is the point. The impenetrability is the point. Now in Victorian schools, and this persisted well into the late 20th century, you would learn the rules of the school and the special language of the school, and you would be given a test after two weeks. And if you didn't pass it, you would be beaten, you know, or you would be punished in some way. Now, Harry, when he arrives, you know, he's nervous as people are, and he is told and he is made to learn the rules of the
自律是一种积极的善，这就是“咬紧牙关”。这正是“咬紧牙关”，你知道，你在苏丹和戈登将军一起在炮火下，你却不露声色。我的意思是，对于一个帝国强权来说，拥有这种特质真的很重要。但我的意思是，在国际上，这成为了英国绅士的形象，他冷漠、无情，血管里流着冰。詹姆斯·邦德什么也不是，我的意思是，正如我们之前在詹姆斯·邦德那一集里谈到的，他如果不是一个公学英雄，就什么也不是，一个典型的公学英雄，正如你所说，汤姆，血管里流着冰。
school. His peers in Gryffindor, his house and the senior children in Gryffindor are guiding the juniors and explaining to them the rules of the sports, all of this kind of thing. The other thing, one thing they don't have in Hogwarts, which is part of the regimentation of the Victorian public school, the regimentation of the Victorian public school went hand in hand with a kind of cult of emotional reserve, of not exposing your emotions. I mean, the importance of that is- Of not crying because you're missing mummy. Right. It's self-discipline. But it's not just a way of beating homesickness. The point, I mean, the Victorian teachers in the shadow of arnold believed that
当然，军事化、竞争和自律精神灌输给男孩们的一种方式是通过体育。这就把我们带到了魁地奇。所以魁地奇，汤姆，你还没读过所有的《哈利·波特》故事，对吧？我没读过所有的。但你知道什么是魁地奇，对吧？是的，我读过一些，也看过电影。所以是的，当然。我的意思是，每个人都知道。魁地奇在某种程度上是一个虚构的、复杂的、离奇的、荒谬的运动。但当然，所有的运动，你知道，板球，对我们许多美国听众来说，它并不比板球或棒球更重要。
self-discipline was a positive good well this is the stiff upper lip it's exactly stiff upper lip it's the you know you're under fire in the sudan with with general gordon and you don't show a flicker of it i mean it's really important for an imperial power to have this kind of but i mean internationally this becomes the image of the English gentleman, that he's cold, emotionless, ice in his veins. James Bond is nothing, I mean, as we talked about before in our James Bond episode, he's nothing if not a public school hero, a classic public school hero, the ice in his veins, as you say, Tom.
好吧，是的，美式足球当然是终极荒谬的运动，或者橄榄球——所以橄榄球是在拉格比学校发明的——这是一种升华的暴力，因为这就是重点，不是吗？所有的这些运动基本上都是各个公学特有的。是的，这种对游戏进行编纂的狂热，从长远来看，将融入像足球和橄榄球等游戏的编纂中。是的。公学男孩当然在这一切中起到了关键作用。但你仍然有著名的伊顿墙球，这很像魁地奇。我不太知道它是什么，但我猜它涉及一堵墙，而且似乎涉及人们在泥里打滚。但伊顿墙球是当时许多此类游戏之一。它之所以引人注目，只是因为它幸存了下来。大多数学校都有伊顿墙球的版本或类似的东西，某种奇怪的游戏。所以我想在切特豪斯学校，他们有一种游戏，有点像橄榄球，只是他们用男孩代替球。有一个男孩死了。那让他变得坚强了。但多米尼克，反过来说，我的意思是，板球很独特，因为到这个时候它已经是国民运动了。所以在《汤姆·布朗的学校时代》里，我想是斯科特·伊斯特或那些家伙中的一个说，板球是英国男孩的与生俱来的权利，无论老少，就像人身保护令和陪审团审判是英国男人的权利一样，这是一个值得你深思的精彩观点。但我认为19世纪板球发生的事情是，公学对板球的拥抱将其从人们玩的一种有趣游戏提升了。他们像斯科特·伊斯特那样，给板球注入了这种道德上的阿诺德式的——再次，著名地不仅仅是一场游戏，而是一种制度，他们说。
And of course, one way that the regimentation, the competition and the spirit of self-discipline, one way that they are all inculcated in the boys is through sport. So this brings us to Quidditch. So Quidditch, Tom, you haven't read all the Harry Potter stories, have you? I haven't read all of them. But you know what Quidditch is, right? Yeah, I've read some of them and I've watched the film. So yeah, of course. I mean, everybody does. It's part of what everybody knows. So the joke about Quidditch to some degree is that Quidditch is a kind of made up, intricate, bizarre, absurd sport. But of course, all sports, you know, cricket, to many of our American listeners, it's no
是的，完全正确。这是一种公学道德主义的宏大感，你知道，人们现在在19世纪末应用到所有这些游戏中的科林斯精神。有趣的是，顺便说一句，阿诺德博士本人对体育一点也不感兴趣，是他的追随者们做出了将体育制度化的伟大尝试。人们现在有时抱怨英国私立学校太关注体育。但在1880年代的阿平汉姆学校，例如，男孩们每天都进行大量的足球运动。
matter than cricket or baseball. Well, yes, American football is the ultimate ridiculous sport of course but um or rugby so rugby devised at rugby school um it's this kind of sublimated violence because that's the thing isn't it that that all these sports are individual to various public schools basically yeah and it's this mania for codifying games that in the long run will feed into the codification of games like football and rugby and so on. Yeah. Public school boys, instrumental, of course, in all of this. But you still famously have the Eton Wall Game, which is quite quidditchy. I didn't really know
校长强迫他们这样做。像伊顿这样的学校会有各种各样的运动，因为体育被视为本质，它被视为——我敢说，汤姆，被神圣化了——被视为男子气概和道德品质的绝对本质。但它不是也被奉为圭臬吗？我们之前提到过“兽性”，作为一种阻止男孩沉迷于女孩和其他男孩的方式。我想没有……或者我可以说是……我想没有……我只能说，我不认为有什么大的担忧。
what it is, but I imagine it involves a wall and it seems to involve people rolling in mud. But the Eton Wall Game is one of many such games at the time. The only reason that's notable is because it's survived. Most schools had versions of the Eton wall game or something similar, some kind of weird game. So I think at Charterhouse, they had a game which was a bit like rugby, except they used boys instead of balls. And one boy died. That toughened him up. But Dominic, just against that, I mean, cricket is distinctive because already by this point, it is a national sport. And so in Tom Brandt, you have, I think it's Scott East or one of those chaps, says of cricket that it is the birthright of British boys, old and young, as habeas corpus and trial by jury are of British men, which is a splendid sentiment that you would do well to reflect upon. But I think what happens in the 19th century with cricket is that the public school embrace of cricket kind of elevates it from a fun game that people played. They imbue cricket, just like Scott East does it there, with this kind of moral Arnoldian- Again, famously more than a game, an institution, they say.
关于男孩在这一时期沉迷于女孩。我认为男孩沉迷于其他男孩的问题是其中的一部分。我们稍后会谈谈“兽性”，但关于体育有一点。所以，是的，一些校长沉迷于“兽性”的危险，他们认为对抗它的最好方法是让男孩们整天做体育运动，这样他们就太累了，没法想别的事情。还有冷水澡吗？他们有冷水澡吗？他们必须有，是的，当然有。然而，一些老师认为，
Yeah, exactly. It's this sort of grandiosity of the sort of public school moralism you know the corinthian spirit that people apply to all these games now by the end of the 19th century the funny thing is actually by the way dr arnold himself wasn't interested in sports at all it was his disciples who made this great attempt to institutionalize sport people sometimes complain now that British private schools are too concerned about sport. But in the 1880s at Uppingham School, for example, boys played vast quantities of football every single day.
他们注意到男孩们在运动时，例如他们的腿是露出来的。所以有一个奇妙的故事，在拉格比学校，一个老师让所有的男孩都穿非常长的短裤。然后短裤的末端用橡皮筋固定。这样其他男孩在踢足球或橄榄球时就看不到任何皮肤，以免他们对彼此产生兴奋。天哪。所以，是的，你在比利·邦特的故事里看不到那个，汤姆。读过《哈利·波特》的人都知道的一件事是，有一种运动员崇拜，比如维克多·克鲁姆或塞德里克·迪戈里。
The headmaster made them do it. Schools like Eton would have a huge variety of sports that people would be doing because sport was seen as the essence of, it became seen it became dare i say sacralized tom as the absolute essence of manliness and moral character but was it not also enshrined and you we mentioned beastliness before as a way of stopping boys from obsessing about girls and other boys i think there's no or i can say it's i don I think there's no... All I can say is I don't think there's any great concern
塞德里克·迪戈里是我最像的角色，汤姆，因为我像塞德里克·迪戈里一样，在赫奇帕奇，一个有很多善良和谦虚男孩的学院。他是学校里的佼佼者，不是吗？他是个了不起的家伙。如果有一部关于《历史的其余部分》的电影，他会由罗伯特·帕丁森扮演，就像我一样。所以如果你认识罗伯特·帕丁森。是的，那个吸血鬼家伙。
about boys obsessing about girls in this period. I think the issue of boys obsessing with other boys is part of it. We'll talk about the beastliness a bit later, but just one thing about sport. So, yes, some headmasters are obsessed with the dangers of beastliness and they uh they they make they believe that the best way to do this to fight it is for the boys to do nothing at sport all day so they're too tired to think about anything else and cold showers do they have cold showers they must they do yeah of course they do however some masters think that
吸血鬼家伙。他会扮演我。你，当然，会在公学故事里由汤姆·赫兰德扮演。所以是的，有运动员崇拜。当然，这导致了这种崇拜，不仅是运动员学生，后来还有士兵，很多J.R.R.托尔金，他以前的橄榄球队，
they notice that the boys obviously when they're playing sport, their legs, for example, are exposed. So there's a fantastic story that at rugby, the guy, one master, he made all the boys wear really long shorts. And then the ends of the shorts were fastened with elastic bands. So no hint of flesh could be seen by the other boys in case they became excited by one another while they were playing football or rugby or whatever. Cripes. So, yeah, you don't get that in the Billy Bunch stories, Tom. One thing that people who've read Harry Potter will know is that there is this kind of cult of the athletes, so Victor Crumb or Cedric Diggory.
几乎所有人都参加了第一次世界大战。很多人被杀了。所以运动队和军事服务的团队合作之间有一种联系，为帝国服务，你在那首著名的亨利·纽博尔特的诗中可以看到。而这在适当的时候，又被视为英国颓废的一种指标，讽刺的是。所以吉卜林有关于“泥泞的笨蛋”和“法兰绒傻瓜”的著名诗句。泥泞的笨蛋，完全正确。我们应该谈谈魔法，当然，汤姆。是的，在课程中，哈利实际上被教导了一种外人绝对无法理解的离奇且深奥的代码，
Cedric Diggory is the character that I most resemble, Tom, because I, like Cedric Diggory, am in Hufflepuff, the house of very kind boys and modest boys. And he's the cock of the school, isn't he? He's a tremendous fellow. He's played, as I would be, if there were a film with the rest is history, by Robert Patterson. So if you know Robert Patterson. Yeah, the vampire guy.
但这起到了将霍格沃茨的学生团结在一起，作为一个独立于外部世界的社区的作用，所以这就是魔法，魔法。除你武器。或者在现实生活中，当然，它是古典学。太棒了。所以公学对拉丁语和希腊语的迷恋。这在某种程度上是中世纪时期的遗留物，但是……当然还有文艺复兴时期，正如我们将要讨论的那样。是的，当然。
Vampire guy. He would play me. You, of course, would be played by Tom Holland in a public school story. So yeah, there's the cult of the athlete. And of course, that leads into the kind of cult of this sort of, not just the sportsman schoolboy, but later on the soldier, lots of Gerald R. Tolkien, his former rugby team,
我的意思是，人们一直都在教古典学。我的意思是，古典学从一开始就存在。我的意思是，古典学从14世纪公学建立之初就一直存在，正如我们下次要讨论的那样。但有一本由学者詹姆斯·布鲁克·史密斯写的精彩书籍叫《镀金青年》。他说，
virtually all of them kind of enlist in the Great War. Lots of them are killed. So there's a kind of link between the sporting team and the sort of the teamwork of military service, service for the empire, which you get in that famous Henry Newbolt poem. And which in due course, again, comes to be seen as a kind of index of British decadence, ironically. So Kipling has the famous lines about muddied oafs and flannel fools. Muddied oafs, exactly. We should talk a bit about magic of course tom yes so in his lessons harry is taught effectively a bizarre and impenetrable code that outsiders cannot possibly understand
古典研究深刻的语言疏离感形成了一个复杂的规则和条例网络，将个人纳入了机构的集体生活中。他说，为什么这么多公学对拉丁语和希腊语的研究如此防御，而他们之后再也没用过？因为它们带有公学入会仪式的不可磨灭的印记。拉丁语和希腊语既是身份形成的工具，也是知识体系。对许多人来说，它们的吸引力在于理性之外的领域，
but which works to kind of bind the pupils at hogwarts together as a community separate from the outside world so that's magic magic. Expelleramas. Or in real life, of course, it's classics. Tremendous. So the fetish of Latin and Greek at public schools. This is a leftover from the medieval period to some degree, but... And definitely the Renaissance, as we will discuss. Yeah, of course.
以及教育的功利性关注。那是魔法，汤姆。所以那些没有拉丁语和希腊语的人就是麻瓜。完全正确，汤姆。完全正确。所以那些在《哈利·波特》宇宙中不是男女巫师的人。你认为这公平吗？
I mean, people have taught classics all the way through. I mean, classics have been there from the way through. I mean, classics have been there from the very beginning of the public schools in the 14th century all the way through, as we will discuss next time. But there's a brilliant book called Gilded Youth by an academic called James Brooke Smith. He says,
我认为正是如此。拉丁语和希腊语是你在寄宿学校会遇到的一系列秘密语言之一。所以另一种秘密语言是学校本身的语言，带有所有奇怪的术语。俚语之类的。小卖部等等。但我认为秘密语言的想法在所谓的公学幽默中非常重要。太多的英国幽默，精英幽默，是关于机构、秘密语言和类似事物的。所以刘易斯·卡罗尔，1950年代的莫尔斯沃思故事，
the profound linguistic alienation of classical study formed a complex network of rules and regulations that subsumed the individual within the collective life of the institution. He says, why is it that so many public school was so defensive about the study of Latin and Greek, which they've never used since? It's because they bear the indelible stamp of the public school initiation right. Latin and Greek were tools for identity formation as much as they were bodies of knowledge. For many, their appeal lay in a realm beyond the rational
《世纪人》，蒙提·派森，你知道吗？是的。蒙提·派森的荒诞主义，经常是关于讽刺机构和嘲笑机构的语言。我认为那是典型的公学幽默。《私家侦探》杂志。完全正确。我们还没谈到老师。
and utilitarian concerns of education. That's magic, Tom. And so those who don't have Latin and Greek are muggles. Exactly. Equivalent, Tom. Exactly. So people who in the Harry Potter universe aren't witches or wizards. Yeah. Do you think that's fair?
从一开始，哈利·波特就特别害怕一位老师，斯内普教授。实际上，霍格沃茨的大多数老师都相当温和。我想说，这在维多利亚时代的公学里并不总是这样。所以它们充满了可怕的艾伦·里克曼式的斯内普教授形象。当然，男孩最害怕的事情莫过于惩罚，即殴打。我们最近做了一个关于萨德侯爵的播客。他会喜欢19世纪英国寄宿学校的生活，汤姆。好吧，他喜欢军事化、去个性化等等，
I think that's exactly it. Latin and Greek is one of a series of secret languages that you will get at a boarding school. So the other secret language is the language of the school itself with all the weird terms. The slang and things. The slang and the tuck shop and so on. But the idea of the secret language, I think, is really important in what you might call public school humor. So much British humor, elite humor, is about institutions and secret languages and things. So Lewis Carroll, the Molesworth stories in the 1950s,
这基本上就是维多利亚时代公学的全部内容。是的。所以20世纪有一位伟大的加拿大社会学家叫欧文·戈夫曼，他谈到了“全控机构”。而维多利亚时代的公学就是终极的全控机构。但这正是它们作为故事如此有效的原因，因为这是一个自给自足的世界。实际上，《星际迷航》也是如此。我一直在读的帕特里克·奥布莱恩的《奥布里和马图林》系列也是如此，实际上，拥有自己等级制度、规则和语言的自给自足的世界对于故事来说是极好的。当然是这样。孩子们崇拜它们。
the Centrinians, Monty Python, you know? Yeah. The absurdism of Monty Python, which is so often about sending up institutions and mocking the language of institutions. That's very public school humor, I would argue. Private eye. Exactly. We haven't talked about the teachers.
评论家凯瑟琳·休斯多年前在写关于《哈利·波特》的吸引力时说，那些永远不会去寄宿学校的孩子们通常喜欢寄宿学校的故事，因为他们喜欢所有必须学习的规则、学校的所有传统、行为准则的想法。我记得给凯蒂读的时候，她还小，我的大女儿，所以她要去当地的公立学校。所以绝对没有学院或去寄宿学校的火车之类的东西。但她崇拜的书是伊妮德·布莱顿的《圣克莱尔的双胞胎》，这也有点像《马洛里塔》，是关于女子寄宿学校的。我记得当我给她读这些小说中的最后一本时，她泪流满面，因为她再也听不到它们第一次出现时的样子了。
Right from the start, Harry Potter is frightened of one teacher in particular, Professor Snape. Actually, most of the teachers at Hogwarts are pretty benign. This was maybe, I think it's fair to say, not always the case at Victorian public schools. So they're full of terrifying Alan Rickman, Professor Snape figures. And of course, the thing that a boy would fear more than anything else is punishment, is beating. And we did a podcast recently about the Marquis de Sade. He would have loved life in a British boarding school in the 19th century, Tom. Well, he loved regimentation and depersonalization and all that kind of thing,
天哪。这绝对证明了这些故事对21世纪对这个世界一无所知的孩子们仍然具有不可思议的吸引力。好吧，任何给孩子读过《哈利·波特》书籍或看到孩子读《哈利·波特》书籍的父母都会知道学校故事所能拥有的力量。我读《比利·邦特》时就是那样。我大约10岁时发现了《比利·邦特》。关于翻译维吉尔和殴打之类的事情让我感到困惑，但我对它上瘾了。所以关于殴打，汤姆，我知道你喜欢殴打。作为维多利亚时代公学制度化的一部分，
which is basically what Victorian public schools are all about. Yeah. So there's a great Canadian sociologist in the 20th century called Irving Goffman, and he talked about total institutions. And the Victorian public school was the ultimate total institution. But that is why they work so well as stories, because it's a self-contained world. And actually, it's true of Star Trek. It's true of the Aubrey and Maturin books that I've been reading, the Patrick O'Brien, that actually self-contained worlds with their own hierarchies, their own rules, their own language are brilliant for stories. Of course they are. And kids adore them.
鞭打或殴打的公共仪式对此绝对是核心。所以在切特豪斯学校，人们会被一束桦木条殴打。在拉格比学校，他们有一根细木藤条，而且有铅。末端用铅加重。你通常会被打在臀部上。学校里会有专门的鞭打台，像一种祭坛，像木制祭坛。这持续了多久？哦，我的意思是，几十年。带有桦木条和铅的藤条……
The critic Catherine Hughes, many years ago, was writing about Harry Potter, the appeal of Harry Potter. And she said, children who are never going to go to a boarding school often love boarding school stories because they love the idea of all the rules they have to learn, all the traditions of the school, the codes of conduct. I remember reading to Katie when she was young, my elder daughter, so she was going to the local state school. So absolutely no houses or trains off to boarding schools or whatever. But the book that she adored were the Twins at St. Claire's by Enid Blyton, which is kind of like Mallory Towers as well, which is about girls boarding schools. And I remember when I read her the last of these novels that she burst into tears because she would never hear them again for the first time.
是的。持续到什么时候？第二次世界大战后，它开始衰落。是的。人们认为这不合规矩。天哪。我不知道。我以为是拖鞋。你经常会被，其他男孩会聚集在一起。那将是一个盛大的公共奇观。哦，这是一种“如果”，不是吗？这是一种“如果”。在伊顿公学，你会走上楼梯去校长的书房。楼梯两旁会站满男孩。
Oh my word. Absolute kind of evidence for the incredible hold that these stories can still have on children in the 21st century who know nothing about this world. Well, any parent who's read the Harry Potter books to their children or seen their children read the Harry Potter books will know the power that the school story can have. I was like that with Billy Bunto. I discovered Billy Bunto when I was about 10. It was baffling to me, a lot of the stuff about translating Virgil and the beatings and stuff, but I was addicted to it. So just on the beatings, Tom, I know you love a beating. As part of the institutionalization of Victorian public schools,
就像被带去断头台一样。你可以想象那种气氛。有些男孩脸上带着同情。其他男孩脸上带着幸灾乐祸，因为受害者是……历史学家希瑟·埃利斯说，这有一种政治共鸣，实际上英国帝国遇到的麻烦越多，似乎公学就越热衷于鞭打，因为他们更担心塑造性格和纪律。社会整体对国家状况的焦虑感越强，
public ritual of flogging or beating was absolutely central to this. So at Charterhouse, people would be beaten with a bunch of birch switches. At rugby, they had a thin wooden cane and they had lead. It was weighted with lead at the end. And you were generally beaten on the buttocks. They would have special flogging blocks at schools, like a kind of altar, like a wooden altar. How long did this go on for? Oh, I mean, decades. Canes with birches and lead on the...
殴打、鞭打、藤条似乎就越多。好吧，我的意思是，你认为这是因为对“法格”和被殴打的痴迷，是为了训练你出去——我想是的，绝对。统治别人，有仆人并殴打他们。所以我为了准备这一集，读了一本大卫·特纳写的非常好的书，《老男孩：公学的衰落与兴起》。他在1928年引用了哈罗公学的一位老师的话，学习服从作为一名“法格”是英国公学制度本质的一部分。那些希望统治的人必须首先学会服从。我想这对统治阶级来说有一个明显的关联，
Yeah. Kind of up to when? After the Second World War, it started to decline. Yeah. People thought this was poor form. Blimey. I had no idea. I thought it was the slipper. You would often be, other boys would assemble. It would be a great public spectacle. Oh, it's an if, isn't it? It is an if. At Eton, you would go up the stairs to the headmaster's study. The stairs would be lined by boys.
他们对帝国可能崩溃感到焦虑。是的。你将从公学进入另一个机构。可能是英国国教会，可能是公务员系统，你将成为印度的殖民官员，可能是陆军或海军。所以你将进入另一个等级制度，在那里你将再次处于底层，你必须努力爬到顶端。所以那种服从和下达命令的想法，真的非常非常重要。殴打的另一个后果，汤姆，一位历史学家估计，19世纪末英国出版的所有色情作品中，约有一半以鞭笞为关键
Like being taken to the guillotine. You can imagine the atmosphere. Some boys, their faces stricken with fellow feeling. Other boys, their faces contorted with glee as the victim was. The historian Heather Ellis says that this had a kind of political resonance, that actually the more trouble the British Empire was in, the more it seems that public schools were keener on flogging because they're more anxious about forming character and about discipline. That the greater the sense of anxiety in society as a whole about the state of the nation,
主题。好吧，这是“英国生活”，不是吗？《鞭笞女主人》、《鞭笞史》、《桦木纪律的精髓》。这些都是书名。不仅如此，这些书是针对公学读者的，因为它们对工人阶级读者来说太贵了。要两三个几尼。所以换句话说，你必须有钱才能买到它们。它们针对的是特定的客户群。伦敦还有专门的鞭笞妓院。但不仅仅是在伦敦，对吧？我的意思是，在巴黎以及整个欧洲大陆也是如此，
the more beatings, floggings, canings seem to have increased. Well, I mean, do you think that this is, hence the obsession with fagging and being beaten, is that this is schooling you then to go out and- I think so, absolutely. Dominate people, have servants and beat them. So I was reading a very good book by David Turner, The Old Boys, The Decline and Rise of the Public School, in preparation for this. And he quotes a teacher at Harrow School in 1928, that to learn to obey as a fag is part of the routine that is the essence of the English public school system. Those who hope to rule must first learn to obey. And that has an obvious relevance, I guess, for a ruling class
因为这再次被视为一种非常英国式的专业。没错，没错。毫无疑问，它来自学校。所以一位名叫乔治·坎农的色情出版商，他写过关于这些妓院的文章，他说，为什么它们如此受欢迎？因为成百上千的年轻人，由于在老师喜欢施加桦木纪律的机构中受教育，并回忆起由此产生的某种感觉，已经对它产生了热情，并渴望从一个漂亮女人的手中接受同样的惩罚。所以即使在当时，人们也认为，嗯，这里发生了一些奇怪的事情。当然，你之前提到过关于男孩们互相干扰的焦虑。
that is anxious about the possible collapse of the empire. Yeah. You're going to go on from a public school into another institution. It could be the Church of England, it could be the civil service, you're going to be a colonial official in India, it could be the army or the navy. So you're going to move into another hierarchy where you will be once again at the bottom and you'll have to work your way up to the top. So that idea of obedience and giving orders, it's really, really important. One other consequence of the beatings, Tom, one historian reckons that about half of all the erotic works published in late 19th century Britain had flagellation as the key
它们绝对存在。所以西奥，我们的制片人，他在惠灵顿公学。我们要去哪里？他可能能够阐明他们是否仍然必须在宿舍隔间的顶部安装铁丝网，汤姆。那是他们做的吗？为了阻止男孩们在晚上溜出来互相干扰，在老师背后。好吧，所以我们有西奥。让我们问问西奥。
theme. Well, it's La Vie Sanglaise, isn't it? The Mistress of Flagellation, The History of the Rod, The Quintessence of Birch Discipline. These are the titles. Now, not only that, these are books aimed at a public school audience because they are too expensive for working class readers. There are two or three guineas. So in other words, you have to be rich to buy them. They're aimed at that particular clientele. There are also special flagellation brothels in London. But not just in London, right? I mean, in Paris as well and across the continent,
这是在你……发生的事情吗？他没回答。谢谢你，多米尼克。是的，我可以确认。我在那里的时候已经不是那样了。好的，谢谢西奥。西奥的精彩贡献，很高兴西奥在节目中。所以在我们继续讨论我们完全没有谈论的事情之前，还有一件事，这是典型的“历史的其余部分”，我们没有谈论女孩……男孩们不仅仅是在互相干扰。有一个非常著名的故事，由一个叫约翰·阿丁顿·西蒙兹的人写的。
because this is seen again as a kind of very English specialization. Right, right. And there's no doubt that it comes from the schools. So a pornographic publisher called George Cannon, who wrote about these brothels, he said, why are they so popular? Because hundreds of young men, through having been educated at institutions where the masters were fond of administering Birch discipline and recollecting certain sensations produced by it, have imbibed a passion for it and have longed to receive the same chastisement from the hands of a fine woman. So even at the time, people think, hmm, there's something odd going on here. And of course, you mentioned before anxieties about the boys interfering with each other.
现在，约翰·阿丁顿·西蒙兹是1850年代哈罗公学的学生，他那段时间的回忆录直到1984年才出版，汤姆，因为它太丑闻了。约翰·阿丁顿·西蒙兹说，在哈罗，当你到达时，长得好看的男孩会立即被大男孩起女性名字。好吧，那是在《汤姆·布朗的学校时代》里。
They are definitely there. So Theo, our producer, who was at Wellington College. Where are we going with this? He may well be able to shed some light on whether they still have to install barbed wire entanglements on the top of the dormitory cubicles, Tom. Is that what they did? To stop the boys breaking out at night to interfere with each other after the master's back. Well, so we've got Theo. Let's ask Theo.
是的，《汤姆·布朗的学校时代》里有暗示。好吧，不，所以他们说，你知道，亚瑟，那个祈祷并喜欢色情的人，显然是弱者。这指的是他和像他一样的新男孩，这个新男孩很可能永远不会脱掉衣服，会害怕湿脚，总是被嘲笑，被称为“莫莉”或“珍妮”或其他贬义的女性昵称。是的。但他们被称为“莫莉”和“珍妮”并不是以贬义的方式。他们被称为“莫莉”和“珍妮”是以一种评估的方式。因为约翰·阿丁顿·西蒙兹说。
Is this what happened at your... He's not replying. Thanks for that, Dominic. Yeah, I can confirm that. That was no longer the case when i was there okay thank you theo excellent contribution there from theo it's great it's great it's great to have theo on the show so just one more thing before we move on to um something we have not talked about at all this is classic rest is history we haven't talked about girls um The boys are not just interfering with one another. There's a very famous story by a guy called John Addington Simmons.
肯定是一样的。好吧，他说会发生的是，长得好看的男孩，你会被一个大男孩收养，作为，我引用，“他的婊子或他的荡妇”，然后你会执行各种服务。西蒙兹说，在1850年代的哈罗，一个人无法避免看到手淫、互相自慰、裸体运动的行为。
Now, John Addington Simmons was a harrow in the 1850s, and his memoir of his time there was not published until 1984, Tom, because it was so scandalous. John Addington Simmons said, at Harrow, when you arrived, the better-looking boys were immediately given female names by the older boys. Well, that's in Tom Brown's school days.
男孩们睡在一起。现在，我们的执行制片人托尼·帕斯托，汤姆，对这种事情很着迷。当我们去美国进行美国巡演时，他在去程的整个飞行过程中都在不停地盘问我寄宿学校发生了什么。我们做过这个、那个和其他事情是真的吗？所以他会喜欢这个。
Yeah, there's a hint of that in Tom Brown's school days. Well, no, so they say that, you know, Arthur, the guy who prays and likes eroticism, is obviously weed. And it's referring to him and other kind of new boys like him, that this new boy would most likely never get out of the clothes and would be afraid of wet feet and always getting laughed at and called Molly or Jenny or some derogatory feminine nickname. Yes. But they're not being called Molly and Jenny in a derogatory way. They're being called Molly and Jenny in an appraising way. Because John Arlington Simmons said.
有一次，西蒙兹最好的朋友，一个叫阿尔弗雷德·普雷塔的人来找他，他说，我有有趣的消息。我实际上一直在和校长有染。哇。所以校长。哇。所以校长是阿诺德的追随者之一，一个叫查尔斯·沃恩的人。我不应该笑。他在28岁时就成为了哈罗公学的校长。
It's the same, surely. Well, he said what would happen is the better looking boys, you would be adopted by an older boy as, and I quote, his bitch or his tart, and then you would perform various services. Simmons said that at Harrow in the 1850s, one could not avoid seeing acts of onanism, mutual masturbation, the sports of naked
肯定是一样的。嗯，他说会发生的情况是，长得好看的男孩会被一个大一点的男孩收养，我引用一下，作为“他的婊子”或“他的荡妇”，然后你会提供各种服务。西蒙斯说，在19世纪50年代的哈罗公学，人们无法避免看到手淫、互相自慰的行为，以及赤身裸体的运动。
boys in bed together. Now, our executive producer, Tony Pastor, Tom, is obsessed by this kind of stuff. When we went to America for the American tour, he spent the entire flight on the way out endlessly quizzing me about what happened at boarding schools. Was it true we'd done this, that, and the other? So he would enjoy this.
男孩们睡在一起。现在，我们的执行制片人托尼·帕斯托，汤姆，对这类事情非常着迷。当我们去美国进行巡回演出时，他在去程的整个飞行过程中都在不停地盘问我寄宿学校里发生的事情。我们做过这个、那个和其他事情是真的吗？所以他会喜欢这个的。
At one point, Simmons' best friend, a guy called Alfred Preta, comes to him and he says, I've got interesting news. I've actually been having an affair with the headmaster. Wow. So the headmaster. Wow. So the headmaster was one of Arnold's disciples, a man called Charles Vaughan. I shouldn't laugh. He had become headmaster of Harrow at 28.
有一次，西蒙斯最好的朋友，一个叫阿尔弗雷德·普雷塔的人来找他，说：“我有个有趣的消息。我其实一直在和校长有私情。”哇。所以校长……哇。所以这位校长是阿诺德的门徒之一，一个叫查尔斯·沃恩的人。我不该笑的。他在28岁时就成为了哈罗公学的校长。
You know how cricketers are talked of as a future England captain, Tom? Yes. He was talked of as a future Archbishop of Canterbury. But presumably this didn't help his cause. It didn't help his cause because basically, Simmons told his father, his father kind of blackmailed Charles Vaughan. Charles Vaughan had to step down as head of Harrow for having had an affair with this boy. And he ended up becoming a parish priest in Doncaster, Tom. Well, bit of a come down.
你知道板球运动员常被谈论为未来的英格兰队长吗，汤姆？是的。他曾被谈论为未来的坎特伯雷大主教。但想必这对他的前途没有帮助。这对他的前途没有帮助，因为基本上，西蒙斯告诉了他的父亲，他父亲某种程度上勒索了查尔斯·沃恩。查尔斯·沃恩因为与这个男孩有染，不得不辞去哈罗公学校长的职务。最后，他成了唐卡斯特的一名教区牧师，汤姆。嗯，真是落魄了。
So that was the end of him. Now, this doesn't happen in Harry Potter for one key reason. Girls. key reason girls hogwarts has girls so hermione granger who is a very very i have to say a very girls school story stereotype isn't she she is just an annoying yeah girly swat she has a blue stocking yeah so um hogwarts has girls of course there weren't co-educational schools in the 19th century they didn't really come in until after the second world war when boys schools started to to admit there were always girls schools tom i know because i you know mallory towers and st claire's exactly the the prototype for a lot of girls schools cheltenham ladies college set up in 1853 and rodine isn't it and rodine 1885 wickham abbey
所以他就那样完了。现在，这种情况在《哈利·波特》中没有发生，原因只有一个：女孩。关键原因就是女孩，霍格沃茨有女孩，所以赫敏·格兰杰，她是一个非常非常，我必须说，非常典型的女子学校故事里的刻板形象，不是吗？她就是一个讨厌的、书呆子气的女孩，一个蓝袜女。所以，嗯，霍格沃茨有女孩，当然19世纪没有男女同校的学校，直到二战后男孩学校开始招收女生，这种学校才真正出现。汤姆，我知道，因为你知道《马洛里塔》和《圣克莱尔》，它们正是许多女子学校的原型，切尔滕纳姆女子学院成立于1853年，还有罗丁，不是吗？罗丁是1885年，威科姆修道院。
1896 downhouse 1907 so often these are schools for people who are going to go overseas. So their parents are going to go overseas. They want their girls to stay in Britain to be educated. Girl schools, I hope girls' school products listening to this will not be offended when I say they were regarded generally as atrocious academically by comparison with the boys' schools. So Cheltenham ladies, they would spend a quarter of their time doing music. A lot of the time they would do needlework. They would learn modern languages, so they would learn French rather than Latin. They do a lot of sport, don't they? They play hockey,
1896年，唐屋中学1907年，所以这些学校通常是为那些要去海外的人准备的。所以他们的父母要去海外。他们希望女儿留在英国接受教育。女子学校，我希望听这个节目的女子学校毕业生不会因为我说她们在学术上与男子学校相比通常被认为很糟糕而感到被冒犯。所以切尔滕纳姆女子学院，她们会花四分之一的时间学习音乐。大部分时间她们会做针线活。她们会学习现代语言，所以她们会学法语而不是拉丁语。她们做很多运动，不是吗？她们打曲棍球，
so jolly hockey sticks and lacrosse. And lacrosse. They don't have the culture of beatings and the sort of physical, all of that stuff. They have a whole load of absolutely mad rules. My favourite ones were from North London Collegiate where girls were banned from gathering in groups of more than three. This was a very serious business. I think it's seen as beastly. I don't know. And the other thing that I love is they were specifically
所以是快乐的曲棍球和长曲棍球。还有长曲棍球。她们没有那种体罚文化，也没有那种身体上的东西。她们有一大堆绝对疯狂的规定。我最喜欢的是北伦敦学院的规定，女孩们被禁止三人以上聚集。这是一件非常严肃的事情。我想这被视为野蛮。我不知道。我喜欢的另一件事是她们被特别
very strictly forbidden from getting wet on the way to school. It was unladylike. Right. And the government did a report in them, it's called the Taunton Commission in the 1860s. And the Taunton Commission said there were two problems with girls' school teaching. One was that the teachers didn't know anything about teaching.
非常严格地禁止在上学路上淋湿。这不淑女。对。政府对她们做了一份报告，叫19世纪60年代的汤顿委员会。汤顿委员会说女子学校教学有两个问题。一个是老师们对教学一窍不通。
And the two was that the teachers didn't know anything about their subjects. But apart from that, they were brilliant. I guess one of the big changes, and this is obviously coincided with JK Rowling starting the Harry Potter series, is that public schools now, they're co-educational and they live or die by their exams. I mean, that's why people spend all the money they do. It's not really to learn character or manliness or womanliness or whatever it is they're teaching. It's basically to get very, very good grades and go to university. But one of the things that Harry Potter does is to kind of re-import that idea of the Victorian idea that you become a better person. And that is something that public schools are now kind of buying into again.
第二个是老师们对她们的学科一窍不通。但除此之外，她们很棒。我想一个巨大的变化，这显然与J.K.罗琳开始写《哈利·波特》系列相吻合，就是现在的公学是男女同校的，而且它们的生存与否取决于考试成绩。我的意思是，这就是人们花那么多钱的原因。这并不是为了学习品格、男子气概或女子气概或任何她们正在教的东西。基本上是为了获得非常非常好的成绩并进入大学。但《哈利·波特》所做的事情之一，就是重新引入那种维多利亚时代的理念，即你成为一个更好的人。而这正是公学现在又开始接受的东西。
That's absolutely central to the public school ethos, Tom. You visit any public school website and they will tell you right from the outset that character, we are forming the citizens of tomorrow, the change makers of the 21st century. But is that actually true or is it just kind of fashionable window dressing? So again, I was reading up that St. Paul's Girl School has actually abolished the title of head girl because it's too binary. Right. Yeah. They're very woke. Some public schools are very woke now. Well, so Eton is decolonizing its curriculum. Yes. So the funny thing about Hogwarts, therefore, Tom, is that Hogwarts, it's multicultural. It has the kind of Patil sisters. It has Lee Jordan, who is black.
这对公学的精神绝对是核心，汤姆。你访问任何公学的网站，他们都会从一开始就告诉你，品格，我们正在塑造明天的公民，21世纪的变革者。但这真的是真的，还是仅仅是一种时髦的门面装饰？所以同样，我读到圣保罗女子学校实际上已经废除了“女学生长”这个头衔，因为它太二元了。对。是的。她们非常觉醒。现在一些公学非常觉醒。嗯，伊顿公学正在对其课程进行去殖民化。是的。所以关于霍格沃茨的有趣之处在于，汤姆，霍格沃茨是多元文化的。它有帕蒂尔姐妹。它有黑人李·乔丹。
Rowling goes out of her way to make it diverse. And the existence of girls means that although it looks like a Victorian public school, in that sense, it's nothing like a Victorian public school because it's far more feminized than a Victorian public school would be. But at the same time, you still have this idea that they are an elite, that they are separate from the muggles. I mean, that remains hard-baked into it. And in that sense, public schools remain absolutely separate from the vast mass of children who are going to state schools or whatever. And I think that that opens up a whole question, which we haven't really discussed in this first episode, which is where do public schools come from? Yeah. And that is something that in your book, The Great British Dream Factory, you talk about. Tom, this is a lovely advert. Thank you. Well, one comment you make about J.K. Rowling is that pace and brevity are not her strong points, though I may not necessarily be the best person to make that observation, which I think is a very wise, self-aware comment to make.
罗琳不遗余力地使其多样化。而女孩的存在意味着，虽然它看起来像一所维多利亚时代的公学，但在那种意义上，它一点也不像维多利亚时代的公学，因为它比维多利亚时代的公学要女性化得多。但与此同时，你仍然有这种想法，即她们是一个精英阶层，她们与麻瓜是分开的。我的意思是，这仍然根深蒂固。从这个意义上说，公学仍然与那些去公立学校的广大儿童完全隔绝。我认为这引出了一个大问题，我们在第一集中还没有真正讨论过，那就是公学从哪里来？是的。这是你在你的书《伟大的英国梦想工厂》中谈到的。汤姆，这是一个可爱的广告。谢谢。嗯，你对J.K.罗琳的一个评论是，节奏和简洁不是她的强项，尽管我可能不是发表这种观察的最佳人选，我认为这是一个非常明智、有自知之明的评论。
Tom, you know I didn't mean it. I don't think that of myself. We absolutely need to finish this episode now. But you do have a very interesting comment about how Hogwarts supposedly is founded before the Norman conquest, and it's a castle to which you attach the footnote. It would probably be unbearably pedantic to observe that this makes Hogwarts very odd since there were no castles in Britain until the Normans arrived. In fact, the first Scottish castles were not built until about 1200. Horrible little boy you must have been. A horrible, horrible little boy. But Tom, I went to a good school and I was made into a fine, upstanding Christian gentleman. A prefect. But I think that that opens up the question of, you know, we've been talking about the Victorian public school and Hogwarts and all the public school stories and traditions that
汤姆，你知道我不是那个意思。我并不那样看自己。我们绝对需要结束这一集了。但你确实有一个非常有趣的评论，关于霍格沃茨据说是建立在诺曼征服之前，它是一座城堡，你为此加了一个脚注。观察到这使得霍格沃茨非常奇怪，因为在诺曼人到达之前英国没有城堡，这可能显得极其迂腐。事实上，第一批苏格兰城堡直到1200年左右才建成。你一定是个可怕的小男孩。一个可怕、可怕的小男孩。但汤姆，我上了一所好学校，我被塑造成了一个优秀的、正直的基督教绅士。一个级长。但我认为这引出了一个问题，你知道，我们一直在谈论维多利亚时代的公学和霍格沃茨，以及所有那些
lie in between Tom Brown's school days and J.K. Rowling. But where did the whole concept come from? How old is it? Does it go back to before the Norman Conquest? If not, when does it go back to? So I think that we should do a separate episode and look at the prehistory of Dr. Arnold and Tom Brown and ask where the public schools come from. Because actually, it's an amazing story that involves riots, the militia being called out and all kinds of extraordinary stories and takes us back to a world that is
介于《汤姆·布朗的学校生活》和J.K.罗琳之间的公学故事和传统。但整个概念是从哪里来的？它有多古老？它能追溯到诺曼征服之前吗？如果不是，它能追溯到什么时候？所以我认为我们应该做一期单独的节目，看看阿诺德博士和汤姆·布朗之前的历史，问问公学是从哪里来的。因为实际上，这是一个令人惊叹的故事，涉及骚乱、民兵被召集以及各种非凡的故事，并将我们带回了一个
actually pretty unfamiliar. Brilliant. Tom, you know I would love that. So everybody, we will see you all next time. But of course, if you are a member of the Rest is History Club, you can listen to Tom. I can imagine that you would like nothing more than to listen to us talking
实际上相当陌生的世界。太棒了。汤姆，你知道我很乐意那样做。所以各位，我们下次再见。但当然，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你可以听汤姆的节目。我可以想象，你没有什么比听我们谈论
even more about public school stories. And we will be doing that on this week's bonus episode for Rest is History Club members only. And of course, if you are a member of the Rest is History Club, if you are a member
更多关于公学故事更感兴趣的了。我们将在本周的奖励剧集中为“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员专门讨论这一点。当然，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，如果你是
of what I like to think of as the prefects, then you can listen to the second episode of this series right now, as is always the way with our chat community. And on that bombshell, Tom, we say goodbye. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
我喜欢称之为级长的一员，那么你现在就可以收听本系列的第二集了，就像我们聊天社区一贯的方式一样。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，我们说再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。